So, auf geht's, wir sagen Poggers, Leute, weil was gibt's heute, das was im Titel steht, heute stimmt der Titel tatsächlich mit dem Inhalt überein, so sieht's aus, ich muss noch kurz was trinken, warte mal, auf geht's,
Gänge in 11 Monate, Pog, oder besser gesagt, die Online-Werbung, ja, manchmal kommt man nicht drumherum, ne, aber wisst ihr was, ich halte die Telekom immer noch für den besten Provider, den wir haben,
leider hat's die Telekom, also qualitätstechnisch, leider hat's die Telekom die letzten Jahre über komplett, oder nicht nur die Telekom,
äh, generell die, äh,
Kupferleitungs-Telefongeschichten,
ja gut, da gibt's außer der Telekom
ehrlich gesagt nicht viel,
die haben's einfach verkackt auszubauen,
unabhängig davon, an wem's jetzt liegt,
auf wen man das jetzt schieben mag,
dass es zu wenig Geld gibt, dass es Stau bei den Auszahlen
von den Geldern gibt, dass es Stau gibt beim
Ausbau, unabhängig davon
stehen die Kabelanbieter
tatsächlich besser da, als die Telekom,
aber, auch
die Kabelanbieter müssen
gucken, was sie mit ihrem Netz machen,
weil ewig können die da auch nicht mehr
mit rumwursten
Telekom
hat halt voll die Arschkarte
überlegt euch mal, VDSL
was ist das schnellste VDSL, was es aktuell
gibt? 250?
Das stinkt halt schon gegen
die theoretische Gigabit-Geschwindigkeit von
Kabel ab, wobei Kabel ist halt auch
Gigabit-Theoretik, nur eine theoretische
Geschichte, wenn du Glück hast, gehst
wenn du Pech hast, geht's nicht
ja, ich glaub 250
und der Witz ist halt, dass 250
ne, das nimmt sich
ping-mäßig nimmt sich das jetzt nicht allzu viel
ähm
das Problem ist
jetzt halt, 250 sieht okay aus
im Jahr 2021
das Problem ist aber, dass nix schnelleres
mehr
in Aussicht ist, also 250
sieht in Ordnung aus, aktuell
aber es ist jetzt schon auf dem
sagen wir mal, auf dem etwas
ja, auf der
langsameren Hälfte, ja
wenn man das mal mit anderen
äh, Ländern auch vergleicht
das ist auf der etwas, etwas langsameren Hälfte, ja
aber es ist okay im Jahr 2021
aber wenn man sich überlegt, da ist halt
der ist jetzt vorbei
ich weiß nicht, hat jemand von euch einen Durchblick?
ich hab das jetzt schon eine Weile nicht mehr verfolgt
wie sieht das aus mit Ausbau?
gibt es demnächst ein super, super
Vectoring oder ist jetzt mit 250
wirklich endgültig
endgültig vorbei, also für mich sieht's so aus
als wäre es endgültig vorbei
vielleicht ganz, ganz
krasse Ausnahmefälle, aber ich glaube, dass es
mit irgendwelchen
Geschichten, äh, ich wohne
gegenüber vom, vom
Endpunkt oder so, aber
ansonsten, was ist denn
ist, ist das, ist das
ist das nicht Glasfaser?
das denke ich mir auch schon seit
einer ganzen Weile, ja, tatsächlich
ich versteh's, ich versteh's auch
nicht so genau, wo das, wo das Problem
ist, Geld
also, ich, ich hab, ich weiß nicht
ehrlich gesagt, woran's genau
hängt, aber Geld scheint ja da zu sein
aber bekommt das organisatorisch
nicht hin
ich glaube, vielleicht wäre
der bessere Ansatz zu sagen, hey
ihr bekommt nur Geld, also
wir bezahlen euch quasi dafür
wenn es denn wirklich da ist
so quasi
wir bezahlen euch tatsächlich für das
Anschließen von Haushalten
egal, ob das jetzt irgendwelche
Bauernhöfe oder sonst was sind
im Prinzip so, wie man's mit den Impfzentren gemacht hat
überlegt euch mal die Impf-
äh, nicht die Impfzentren, meine ich, die, die
Testzentren, mit den Testzentren hat man das
doch auch hingekriegt, man hat gesagt, ey
macht Testzentrum hin,
ihr kriegt Geld dafür, bam, an jeder
Scheiß-Ecke ist ein Testzentrum, ich hab
letztens, ohne Scheiß, Leute, kein Spaß
ich hab nen Dönerladen gesehen
mit nem Test, äh, mit nem Zelt
und nem Testzentrum davor, nen
Dönerladen, da war Kebab
und davor stand ein Zelt
mit Testzentrum
so einfach kann das funktionieren
ganz erstens
kannst du mir hören, ob dein Testergebnis
war, das kannst du Döner fordern
wobei, ein Testergebnis geht ja schnell, aber
ja, äh, kann mal
einer kurz erklären, was Supervektoren ist
also, die technische, ich kann dir erklären
was es ist, aber die technische Seite hab ich
mich nie so genau damit beschäftigt
es ist ne Technik, wie du über die
Oldschool-Kupferleitung, da wo früher
Telefon drüber ging
wie du dort noch ein bisschen mehr
Bandbreite rausholen kannst für
Internetanschlüsse, also Band, generell
Bandbreite für Datenübertragung, muss ja nicht Internet sein
Bandbreite für Datenübergang, also das ist
im Prinzip die weiter
weiter, der Weiterentwicklung
von DSL
hat halt den Nachteil, geht nur über relativ kurze
Strecken, ich weiß, weiß jemand von euch
aus dem Kopf, was maximale Länge
ist, Supervektoring, dass das geht mit
250, das kann
nicht lang sein, Kilometer, wenn es hochkommt, oder?
Wenn es hochkommt
eher, eher weniger
400 Meter, ja, so in einem Dreh
hätte ich mir das jetzt auch gedacht
ja
das ist halt nicht viel, ne, 300 Meter
macht es halt für, macht es halt auf dem Land
teilweise uninteressant, und das ist ja das
eigentliche Problem, was es auch beim Ausbau
gibt, in der Stadt hast du oftmals viele
Alternativen, guck mal, bei mir, ich könnte
Supervektoring von der Telekom nehmen, ich
könnte Gigabit von Vodafone nehmen, wenn ich,
wenn ich ganz, wenn ich ganz Hardcore drauf
bin, könnte ich auch LTE oder demnächst 5G
oder sowas nehmen, oder Telekom Hybrid
oder was auch immer, alles mögliche, bei mir
gibt es ja im Prinzip alles, aber wenn du mal
ein bisschen auf dem Land guckst, in der
Regel ist es so, da wo eins scheiße ist, sind
alle anderen auch scheiße, und das ist halt
Müll, man kann sagen, da wo scheiße ist, ist es halt
scheiße, ey 5G, stimmt, stimmt, ja, Leute, ich
hab's, ich hab's schon wieder ganz vergessen, die
Antenne ist mittlerweile noch größer
geworden, soll ich das mal an, Armleak, die Antenne
geht mir mittlerweile fast schon, fast
schon bis zur anderen Seite rüber, nach
der Impfung, aber, aber mir tut zumindest
der Arm nicht mehr weh, eigener 5G-Mast, ja,
ja, Armleak, hier Bizepsleak, genau, lol, das ist
eh, es sind alles keine Muskeln, es ist alles
Pipo-Fett, nein, ich glaube nicht, dass
Starlink irgendwas ablösen wird, bei uns
in Deutschland, im großen, großen Umfeld,
im großen Stil, das glaube ich, glaube ich
nicht, ja, es gibt, es gibt sicherlich
total viele Varianten, was man machen kann,
wichtig ist im Endeffekt, dass man die für
das, dass man die, dass man die nicht für
die irgendwelche Ausbauten und
Absichtserklärungen bezahlt, sondern die
müssen bezahlt werden dafür, dass sie,
dass sie es gemacht haben, auch mit einer
Auflage, bis dann und dahin, das ist
übrigens das Gleiche, kann sich jetzt, kann
sich noch jemand an die, ähm, UMTS-Auktion
erinnern, von, wann war das denn, äh, äh,
2000, ähm, so, da haben die, ich weiß, das ist
jetzt, das ist jetzt fast, fast schon
Boomer-Zeiten, da gab es vielleicht einige
von euch schon nicht, keine Ahnung,
vielleicht kann sich, vielleicht kann sich
irgendjemand an die UMTS-Aktion, äh, Auktion
erinnern, das war ja damals Big Brain Time,
das so zu machen, man hat ja auch versucht,
äh, so ein spezielles, ich habe vergessen,
wie es heißt, die haben das so ein ganz
spezielles, äh, Ver-, wie nennt man das,
Versteigerungsverfahren gemacht, wo die
Anbieter quasi irgendwie nicht wussten,
was die anderen Anbieter abgeben, um da
möglichst viel Geld rauszubringen, und das ist
das Problem war nur, die Anbieter haben da
so viel Geld bezahlt, und so viel Geld
ausgegeben, und es war einem im Prinzip an
nichts geknüpft, was heißt, was im Endeffekt
heißt, die Anbieter haben sich alle wie
verrückt, äh, ersteigert, übersteigert,
überboten, bis da noch ein paar übrig
geblieben sind, man hat halt damit auch so
effektiv verhindert, dass es mehr Anbieter
als, keine Ahnung, wie gibt's denn Telekom,
äh, wie, oder wie gab's denn, wie gab's denn
damals, Telekom, Vodafone, keine Ahnung,
damals gab's nicht so viele Anbieter,
2, 3, und, so, was haben die jetzt für einen
Anreiz gehabt, ne, E+, genau, E+, ja, und
was haben die jetzt für einen Anreiz
gehabt, in ländlichen Gebieten mit 5
Benutzern auszubauen, gar keinen, 0, die
haben dort ausgebaut, wo es viel Kohle zu
holen gab, weil die haben eh schon so viel
Geld bezahlt, man hat effektiv verhindert,
dass weitere Anbieter dazukommen, die da
irgendwie ein bisschen, äh, ja, das Ganze
aufmischen können, und,
man hat nicht dafür, dadurch auch nicht
dafür gesorgt, dass die ein großes
Interesse haben, überall auszubauen,
deswegen haben wir auch so viele
Funklöcher, bei mir in Maintal, jedes,
jeden, jeden Tag, oder, ich fahr nicht
jeden Tag, aber,
Apps, Google,
Maintal, kennt kein Mensch, aber,
äh,
Ostbahnhof, so,
jeden Tag, wenn ich da vorbeifahre, ich
fahr nicht jeden Tag vorbei, aber,
jedes Mal, jedes Mal, wenn ich da vorbeifahre,
hier, Maintal Ostbahnhof,
äh, zwischen, zwischen Maintal
zu Maintal Ost, jedes Mal, wenn ich da
vorbeifahre,
hier ist die Bahnstrecke,
ist Funkloch, ich weiß nicht, was
die da machen, keine Ahnung, so, und das
Problem mit den UMTS-Auktionen war, dass
die halt keine Anreize hatten, hätte man
gesagt, gut, ich meine, im Nachhinein ist man
immer schlauer, und wenn ich das sage,
heißt das noch lange nicht, dass das funktioniert hätte, aber,
überlegt euch, überlegt euch mal,
man hätte
gesagt, hey, Anbieter,
ihr bekommt die UMTS-Lizenzen,
ihr kriegt die meinetwegen
sogar kostenlos, aber
nur, wenn
ihr euch verpflichtet, auszubauen,
flächendeckend, und ihr kriegt den Kram
nur unter den Auflagen, oder nur,
nachdem wir gesehen haben, ihr macht das, oder
ihr habt auch wirklich einen Plan,
einen überprüfbaren Plan, wie das Ganze
funktioniert, da hättest du gesehen, die wären rumgerannt
am Arsch der Welt und hätten irgendwie Zeug aufgestellt,
ja,
gut, das kann man im Nachhinein immer, immer,
immer gut sagen, und letztendlich, was hat
das Geld gebracht, was man damit eingenommen
hat, weiß ich, ob das,
was damit, ja,
naja, ist das jetzt traditionell,
mach ich doch selten, aber das ist
halt so ein typisches Thema gewesen, UMTS-Auktion,
wo man es meiner Ansicht nach verkackt hat,
ja, hätte man das wirklich,
hätte man wirklich gesagt, hey,
ihr kriegt die unter Auflagen,
dass ihr das und das bis dann
macht, und nicht solche komischen,
nicht solche komischen Sachen,
wie es aktuell immer erzählt wird,
bis 2035 ist das
und das passiert, nee, nee, nee, das muss
kurzfristig sein, es muss gesagt werden, hey, unser Ziel
ist es, keine Ahnung, wenn man 2010
versteigert hat, hat man gesagt, okay, unser
Ziel ist es, 2020 flächendeckend
abgedeckt, und
wir haben einen genauen Plan, und wenn ihr euch nicht dran
haltet, kriegt ihr eure Lizenzen weggenommen,
und hättet ihr mal gesehen, kommt,
wie schnell,
wie gesagt, wie bei Corona-Testzentren,
ey,
die, an jeder Ecke,
die werden amok gelaufen,
okay, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben, aber
die werden amok gelaufen, im UMTS-Masten
aufstellen, ja,
wäre alles, alles,
alles wunderbar funktioniert, und so könnte
man das ja auch beim Festnetzausbau machen,
aber egal, das ist so ein,
ja, ich verstehe sich, übrigens, Leute,
was mich heute mega verwirrt hat,
was mich heute mega verwirrt
hat, ist folgendes Bild von Apple,
guck mal, ich hab dieses Bild von Apple gefunden,
ich hab, ich hab ein iPhone 11 hier, und ich
hab gesucht, iPhone 11
Dual SIM,
und da hab ich dieses Bild gefunden,
von Apple, wie sieht dieses
Bild für euch aus?
Also, auch noch in Deutsch beschrieben,
auch noch in Deutsch, wie sieht dieses Bild für euch aus?
Kann man da zwei SIM-Karten reinmachen,
ja oder nee?
Ich würd sagen, ja, kann man, eine oben, eine unten.
Ich zeig euch auch,
Dual SIM, dass ich keinen Mist erzähle, das ist wirklich
ein, das ist wirklich ein Apple, äh,
ähm, Apple, hier, Bild, da, guck,
ähm,
12 CD's zu Nano, SIM-Karten,
vordere, oder, aber,
ich hab's, und ich hab das,
ich hab das Bild gesehen, hab mir gedacht, nice,
dann kann ich das Handy, was ich von der Firma,
bekomme, auch, äh, für mein
Aldi-Talk verwenden, ich brauch kein zweites Gerät
mehr,
und ich hab's nicht hingekriegt, ich hab mir das einfach gesagt,
Alter, wie um alles in der Welt soll
da die SIM-Karte reinpassen, das funktioniert
überhaupt nicht, bis ich's dann irgendwann
gecheckt habe,
diese Anleitung von Apple hier, komplett in
Deutsch, komplett eingedeutscht, gilt
nur für,
Moment,
in Festland, China, Hongkong und
Macau, ich weiß nicht mal, wo das ist,
China-Chinesen wieder,
Tibet, wo ist das
überhaupt? Ich kann keine
eSIM nehmen, weil Aldi-Talk keine
eSIM anbietet, weil das
irgend so ein richtiger, äh, keine Ahnung,
weiß ich mal,
Boomer-Verein, ne, keine Ahnung,
wo ist das?
Ah,
südliche China,
okay, dann kann man davon ausgehen,
dass die Chinesen der Meinung sind,
das gehört zu China, im Prinzip
ist es ja so, bei allem,
bei allem, was irgendwie um China liegt,
sind die Chinesen der Meinung, das gehört ihnen.
Ist ja, ist ja
hier bei, bei, äh, äh, hier,
Taiwan, ist ja das gleiche.
Taiwan, die Chinesen sind ja auch der Meinung, das, das ist
meins, das ist unsers.
Alles, alles meins.
Naja, aber, ja, hab ich's,
ne, verkackt, ich dachte, das geht.
Aldi-Talk hat leider keine eSIM,
das heißt, ich bräuchte einen anderen Anbieter.
Eigentlich wollte ich aber keinen anderen
Anbieter. Die Festland-China-
Chinesen, genau.
Ah,
A91207,
2, Dankeschön, für 3 Monate
Subscription. Wer soll das denn
ausbauen, wenn nicht die Anbieter?
Die Anbieter haben wenigstens Ahnung von der Technik.
Äh, ja, ja, mach mal
Ausrufezeichen 1 im Chat, da gibt's sogar eine Erklärung
zu, aber es hat keinen tieferen Sinn.
Also, das, es gibt keinen Grund, dass man das
auch so machen müsste.
Ne, ne, es gibt mehr Anbieter mit eSIM, als
die Telekom.
Cellmapper.
Okay.
Nein. Ich suche jetzt, okay,
ich guck mir das jetzt an.
Äh, Cellmapper. Äh,
Provider.
Ah, war ja.
Tele. Komm.
Okay, und wo sucht man da jetzt?
Wo sucht man
da jetzt, äh,
nach, ah hier, Location Search.
Mainthal Ost.
Da sind wir doch.
So, und wo erkenne ich jetzt, ob's da, ob's da
Funklöcher gibt? Also, hier ist
Mainthal Ost.
Da ist Hanau-Wilhelmsbaden, da ist irgendwo
Hanau West, äh, ähm,
Mainthal. Irgendwo ist Mainthal West.
So, und hier dazwischen,
hier dazwischen, kackt mir
regelmäßig der, der, der, die,
die, die,
Handyverbindung ab. Hier so wahrscheinlich.
Guck mal, hier ist doch auch kaum was.
Ja. Ja, davor auch.
Guckt euch das mal an. Ja.
RIP. Ja. Äh, ich weiß noch,
als Corona angefangen hat,
hatten wir eine Video, äh, ne, keine Videokonferenz,
ein Teamscall, wo mein Chef
was erzählt hat zu aktuellen
Entscheidungen auf der Arbeit. Also, letztes,
letztes Jahr im März oder so, wann das war.
Und ich bin gefahren hier
nach Hanau von, äh,
von Frankfurt Ost,
äh, Frankfurt, Frankfurt Süd.
Müsste,
müsste hier irgendwo, irgendwo
sein.
Bin verwirrt, ich weiß nicht, wo das ist.
Aber ich bin gefahren von Frankfurt,
Frankfurt Süd nach Hanau
und es ist fünfmal abgekackt
zwischendurch. Ich hab die Hälfte nicht mitbekommen.
So, ich mach mal, ich mach mal
kurz hier IDE auf.
Ja, wir machen heute am Overlay Champ
ein bisschen weiter. Gucken, wo wir stehen geblieben
sind. Zumal der Source Code
ja eines der hässlichsten
Schau mal, wie es bei dir
zu Hause ist. League!
Äh, eines der hässlichsten
Dinger ist überhaupt, aber wir,
das ist ja auch eigentlich im Prinzip nur alles
untereinander, untereinander geschrieben. Mal gucken, ob es noch
funktioniert.
Oh, oh, Highspeed, Highspeed,
Leute, Highspeed GIF.
Highspeed GIF. Das GIF ist so schnell, dass ihr die Hälfte
der Bilder nicht seht, oder?
MonkaS. Ihr seht's,
ihr seht aber nicht dieses ultraschnelle
Rumgedingse, oder?
Seht ihr das? Moment.
Whoop Lords
auf Twitch.
Ja, doch. Sieht man.
Ist voller Abkacken.
Der rendert grad so schnell, wie es geht GIFs.
Äh, Moment.
Echt, iPhones haben keinen Dual SIM. Ja,
anscheinend nur eine SIM-Karte
und eSIM als zweites.
Naja, ich kann's mir nicht aussuchen.
Ich kann jetzt ja schlecht,
auf die Arbeit gehen und sagen, ja,
also ihr, ihr stellt mir zwar kostenlos
ein iPhone zur Verfügung, aber
äh, iPhone ist
für Kacknoobs, gebt mir ein Android-Gerät.
Aber das kann ich sagen, aber das wird keiner machen.
Weil wenn alle ein iPhone 11
kriegen, dann krieg ich auch ein iPhone 11. Jetzt nicht
das, dass der Weisheitsletzter
Schluss wäre oder so, aber das
betrifft,
jetzt kann ich nix machen.
100% CPU, 100% GPU,
nee, lass mal, ich zeig, Moment,
wir gucken jetzt jetzt mal kurz.
Wir gucken uns mal kurz an,
wie viel CPU-Auslastung das Ganze hat.
Guck mal, fast nix.
Leute, 2% und
GPU.
Soll das nicht eigentlich drinstehen irgendwo?
Ach, hier.
Nix. 3% GPU,
5% CPU, das ist ja, das ist ja nix.
Da wird's einem schlecht, wenn man das
zu lang anguckt. Warum du zwei
SIM-Karten brauchst? Naja, ich will meine private
Telefonnummer und die
SIM-Karte von der Arbeit in einem Gerät
haben, dass ich keine zwei Geräte mehr brauch.
5 Euro.
Beim Chef hab ich da kein Problem, der findet
das wahrscheinlich sogar noch lustig. Aber die, die
das entscheiden können, denen ist das
vollkommen egal. Doch,
wahrscheinlich schon, aber
die werden ja nicht nur für mich eine eSIM
da ausstellen.
Nee, ich frag da nicht.
Ich such mir lieber einen Anbieter mit eSIM.
Kann man eigentlich seine Mobilfunknummer
einfach umziehen? Hab ich noch nie gemacht.
Also wenn ich jetzt von Aldi Talk wechseln will
zu irgendwas mit eSIM, geht das
einfach, genauso einfach wie Festnetznummer,
wechseln, einfach Antrag ausfüllen beim
Nächsten. Ja, ob das ein bisschen was kostet,
interessiert mich nicht.
Also solange das, solange das jetzt
irgendwie 80 Euro kostet oder so, ist okay.
Wenn die 2,50 Euro
als Gebühr haben wollen, interessiert mich das
nicht weiter. Du bist zu was
gewechselt? Frank?
Was ist Frank?
Frank Mobile?
Was für ein Ding?
Was ist das? Das hab ich noch nie gehört.
Ey.
Gibt's irgendwie jeden Tag einen neuen Anbieter
oder was? Außer man hat eine äußerst
hässliche Webseite.
Was ist das? Hab ich noch nie gehört.
Was für
ein Rees?
Woher wissen die, wie ich heiße?
Oder steht
das überall? Oder steht
das überall, Maximilian?
What the fuck?
Nee, das wissen die nicht. Ich geh mal davon aus,
das ist wirklich Max Mustermann.
Ja, und was haben
die irgendwie? eSIM, okay.
Dein Tarif per App?
Frank?
Oder Fraenk?
Flat.
10 Euro pro Monat, nicht mehr.
Gibt's noch was Billigeres?
Sternchen.
Mehr Infos.
Gibt's noch was Billigeres?
Weil ich brauch den Datentarif im Prinzip
kaum noch. Ich brauch's eigentlich nur für
Telefon, weil Datentarif, nämlich
die SIM-Karte von der Arbeit.
Ich brauch das Billigste überhaupt, wo
ich 2-Faktor-SRM,
SMS empfangen kann.
Ach, wurscht. Aber irgendwo anders.
Was? Win-SIM?
Win-SIM? Klingt nach
Scam.
Weiß nicht, manche Anbieter klingen
vom Namen her schon richtig nach Scam.
Aldi hat keine eSIM.
SIM-Quadrat?
Was sind das? Alter,
das ist jetzt Cheap-Aid. Das gibt's
nicht wirklich. SIM-Quadrat, oder?
Das ist für alle
Minecraft-Leute.
Tatsächlich.
SIM-Quadrat.
Oh, weh, Alter.
Die Anbieter-Namen.
Ohne Daten, kein Internet.
Ja, sowas reicht. Ganz ehrlich?
5 Euro. Perfekt. Reicht mir.
eSIM?
Gigabyte Datenvolumen ist okay. Wie gesagt, ich verwende
das eh nicht für Datenvolumen.
Dafür verwende ich die andere SIM-Karte.
Ich brauch eigentlich nur ne Handynummer.
Was kostet
Handynummer umziehen?
Du hast eine Domain, die sehr nah
an Win-SIM dran ist. Die schicken dir
laufend Kündigungen.
Das ist ja auch so, dass ich
bei mir auf der Arbeit, bei mir rufen auch
manchmal verärgerte, verärgerte
Außendienst-Mitarbeiter an und fragen mich,
wo ihre Provision bleibt.
Und da denk ich mir immer so,
warum? Was, hä?
Sie sind hier falsch.
Und das Problem ist halt, dass meine
Telefonnummer fast so weit ist, wie die,
für die Abrechnung für die
Provisionsabteilung für, frag mich nicht,
äh, Hessen Süd oder so.
Da kommen die bei mir an.
Wenn die, also wenn einer
vom Außendienst anruft in der Zentrale
und
sagt, was ist los
mit meiner Abrechnung, dann könnte
der davon ausgehen, er hat in der Regel kein Geld gekriegt
und ist sauer. Ich glaube, so was
mach ich. Und wie funktioniert das?
Einfach ne App installieren und dann, äh,
in den iPhone-Settings hinzufügen,
oder wie?
SIM-Quadrat? Alter, der Name macht mich immer noch fertig.
SIM-Quadrat?
Ich hab das einzige
Remote, was ich quadratisch hab grade.
Ne, ich hab noch ein anderes quadratisches
Emote.
Ah, haha, verstehe.
Ja, muss ich mir mal angucken.
Ich glaube, das werd ich machen.
So.
Los geht's.
Was, ein Brief und dann mit QR-Code, okay.
Ja, das wird
schon tun.
So.
Also, wo sind
wir denn stehen geblieben? Ich würd sagen, als allererstes,
das wichtigste, das mit
Abstand wichtigste Feature, was wir unbedingt
noch brauchen ist, wir brauchen
einen FPS-Counter, Leute.
Ich muss wissen, mit wieviel FPS
RareParrot raret.
Zeig mal her.
Blick ich überhaupt noch durch bei diesem ganzen,
das, ich mein, das ist eines der hässlichsten
Dinger, die ich hier je gebaut hab.
Blick ich überhaupt noch durch, wo hier was passiert?
Wo passiert denn hier was? Ja, am besten,
am besten auch die Variablenamen. Also,
merkt euch, Plup und Temp
sind mit Abstand die besten Variablenamen
überhaupt.
Da weiß man sofort Bescheid, was, wofür
das da ist.
Verwend ich das überhaupt noch irgendwo?
Ach, hier. Okay.
Ach, Lull.
Lull ist, Lull ist auch ein guter Variablenamen.
Ja, aber Temp, Temp oder
I. I und I, N,
Temp und Plup
sind meine. Also, I,
N, Temp, Plup, das sind so meine,
meine, hallo, Lull.
Meine, meine Lieblingsvariablenamen.
Okay, also, wo, wo,
wo mache ich denn hier den Output?
Begin Draw, hier. Also, hier muss ich
FPS hochzählen, glaube ich.
Okay, wir machen mal
einen FPS-Counter kurz.
Äh, FPS,
ne, keine Ahnung.
Auch, auch, auch,
beste, da weiß man auch sofort, für was da gecountet
wird. Oh, ne, O
mache ich nicht. Selbst als,
selbst als, ähm,
äh, Parameter für, mache ich, mache ich,
O, O mache ich eigentlich selten.
Counter, so, und jetzt, Moment.
Wie mache ich denn jetzt am besten einen FPS-Counter?
Irgendwie Stopwatch?
Oh, übrigens, hier, richtig krasse Hacker
meinen Hacks hier, was ich letztens gelernt habe.
Sogar im Stream hat mir jemand
gezeigt, normalerweise habe ich immer gesagt,
Stop, hallo, warte,
Stopwatch, Start.
Das braucht man gar nicht.
Pass mal auf.
Man kann einfach sagen,
Stopwatch,
Alter, Autovervollständigung.
Wo ist denn die Autovervollständigungs-AI?
Wenn man sie braucht.
Start, New.
Das ist nicht POG.
Haben wir eine Zeile gespart.
Richtig, richtig, Six Head.
Wusste ich nicht, hat mir letztens einer
im Stream gezeigt, oder, äh,
im Chat geschrieben.
Da sieht man einfach, der Chat ist wieder richtig,
richtiges Next Level.
Das kann ich gar nicht jeden Stream zeigen,
weil ich das, glaube ich, erst im letzten oder vorletzten
Stream selbst erfahren habe, dass das so funktioniert.
Es wird
nach Line of Kurs bezahlt.
Mist.
Ja, dann sollten wir auch auf Kobol wechseln wieder.
Okay, also,
von der Logik her,
ich zähle, wie viele FPS
ich habe, und dann
sage ich, wenn
meine, mein Timer,
äh,
seconds,
nee, elapsed,
total,
total seconds, größer, gleich,
äh, was? Zwei.
Alter, eins,
dann geben wir aus, wie viele,
nee,
wait a minute, wie viele, wie viele
Frames es sind,
und,
äh, dann
restarte ich
den Timer und setze die Frames
auf null. Okay, mal gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Dann sollte ich ein Frame, so eine Art
Frame Counters,
240, das kann nicht sein,
das ist viel zu wenig.
240 FPS,
ah, das ist vSync, das ist
vSync, da ist vSync an,
ich habe 240 Hz Monitor, warum ist da
vSync, wie kriege ich vSync aus?
vSync muss
aus, aus,
vSync, null, null Sync, Alter.
Du warst irgendwo
bei Sync, habe ich echt Sync?
Äh, ich habe nirgendwo Sync stehen.
Ich habe einen 240 Hz Monitor,
ja.
Intervalle?
Nee.
Äh, ging das nicht hier, Swap, Swap Chain?
vSync?
Und da muss ich mal suchen. Swap Chain
vSync, okay.
Warum streamst du da nur in
48 FPS? Weil die meisten Leute
das überhaupt nicht richtig, also gar keinen
großartigen Mehrwert davon hätten, wenn
ich 240 FPS streame. Und dazu
kommt, warum ich 48 FPS und nicht
60 FPS oder 30 streame, ist,
weil, wenn du
eine gewisse, du hast ja nur eine gewisse
Bandbreite zur Verfügung zum streamen.
So, und wenn du eine feste Bandbreite hast,
dann ist natürlich
für ein Bild mehr Bandbreite
übrig, wenn du weniger FPS
hast. Das ist ein Present.
Ach, guck mal da.
Present.
Das müsste hier unten
sein, irgendwo, ne?
Swap. Ah, hier, hier,
guck mal. Present.
Sync Intervall, null.
So.
Jetzt aber. Jawoll.
Schau mal, viel besser. Guck mal,
jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt stimmt die
Anzeige hinten und vorne schon mal nicht mehr.
Jetzt komplett vorbei.
Warum gehst du nicht auf 30 FPS runter?
Weil, 48 FPS
genau der
beste Kompromiss ist, zwischen
flüssige Wiedergabe und mehr
Bandbreite für den einzelnen Frame übrig.
Jetzt Task Manager. So, aber
da geht noch mehr. Das sind noch ein bisschen wenig FPS.
Da muss noch mehr gehen.
Ok, guck mal.
Jetzt haben wir schon ein bisschen mehr.
15 CPU, 15% GPU.
Da muss, da muss aber
noch ein bisschen mehr gehen.
Naja, woran das beschränkt ist,
der muss das GIF decoden.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das DirectX
Zeug das Problem ist, sondern
der GIF Decoder ist
das Problem. Ich meine, wenn ich
jetzt einfach den GIF
Decoder unabhängig mache,
von dem,
von dieser Schleife,
die das hier malt,
ach stimmt, ich glaube, ich habe sogar noch
Debug laufen, genau, stimmt, hast recht.
Gehen wir mal hier auf.
.NET run.
Wie nennt das so?
Dann würde das sicherlich viel, viel schneller laufen.
Ja, leider auf Windows.
Warte mal, wie war das? Minus C Release, glaub
ne? Ah, macht
keinen, bisschen, bisschen,
aber nicht wirklich viel Unterschied.
Das einfachste wäre,
das einfachste wäre, was ich nicht mache, weil
ich will ja keine 100% CPU Last hier verursachen
oder so, das einfachste wäre natürlich,
ich lass das GIF rendern,
quasi immer,
immer das aktuellste GIF und
schreib das halt so schnell, wie es geht rein
und wenn es ein neues gibt, dann halt ein neues. Aber das ist
bescheuert, wozu? Mein Ziel,
mein Ziel ist ja nicht hier irgendwie
100% CPU Last
mit einem GIF
zu bekommen und
schneller rendern, als der GIF
Decoder das GIF
decoden kann, bringt halt gar nichts.
Ich mein, wir können
mal ausprobieren, wie schnell es maximal
geht. Das können wir
machen, da müsste ich aber irgendwie, alter, das
ist so hässlich, ich blick hier überhaupt nicht mehr durch.
Wo wird dann hier decoded?
Hier. Ah, wir können, ich glaub,
wir können noch ein bisschen was optimieren. Wartet mal,
wir können noch ein bisschen,
wir können noch ein bisschen was
optimieren. Ähm,
wir müssen das nicht jedes Mal
für jeden Schleifendurchlauf anlegen.
Wir müssen das nicht für jeden Schleifendurchlauf
anlegen. Das ist okay.
Ob's jetzt schneller ist,
macht überhaupt keinen Unterschied.
Und was ist, wenn ich das Freigeben wieder rausschmeiße?
Dann hab ich zwar Memory Leak, aber ist schneller.
Okay, das FFmpeg
Memory Handling macht überhaupt keinen Unterschied.
Das ist wirklich das GIF Decoden,
was Probleme macht.
Ich mein, der liest das ja auch
von der SSD und sowas.
Mach Kommentare rein, nä, das lohnt,
das lohnt sich ja alles nicht mehr. Okay,
ähm, ich mein,
nee, da müsste ich das jetzt umbauen.
Wie gesagt, ich splitte das eh auf,
weil das mega hässlich ist.
Also wir machen da eh jetzt gleich ein paar
eigene Klassen. Wir machen ne Klasse
für das FFmpeg Decoder Zeug.
Und dann machen wir,
ähm,
so ne eigene Form fürs Rendern, weil
ich hab ja aktuell hier
alles komplett in einem. Also das
GIF Decoden und
das Rendern von, das DirectX
Rendern ist alles, alles, alles
in einem Thread.
Das heißt, ich krieg, ich kann jetzt gar
nicht sagen, hey, warten wir einfach
mal und zeichnen
so schnell wir können. Das, das funktioniert nicht.
So, aber wir müssen die FPS
da noch irgendwie reinschreiben.
Aber ich finde, ich finde, die
Decoding Geschwindigkeit
ist, wie, wie ist die im Fullscreen?
Genauso schnell. Also die Decoding
Geschwindigkeit mit 1200
FPS und so, das ist durchaus
in Ordnung. Ich mein, ich muss
den Kram eh runterschrauben
auf, ähm,
warte mal, wo steht denn das drinne?
Frame?
Time? Ne, ähm,
ach du Scheiße,
wo steht noch mal drinne, wie viel FPS das
Ganze hat? Stream ist das glaub ich, ne?
Stream? Time?
Timebase, genau.
Das brauchen wir.
Und das kann ich mir nie merken.
Das kann ich mir nie merken.
Timebase, zeigt mal kurz her.
Wir machen prinzipiell
Print, Print Debugging, ne?
Was anderes ist ja, Debugger
Usen ist für Noobs, das machen wir hier nicht.
Äh, 100?
Das, äh,
das GIF hat doch im Leben keine
100, keine 100
100 FPS.
Moment.
Das, das ist glaub ich Mist, was der da ausliest.
Warte mal, das muss ich mir jetzt grad mal im Detail
angucken.
Ein GIF mit 100 FPS, das wär's jetzt aber noch.
Bei Frames gibt's doch, äh,
bei GIF gibt's doch pro Frame ne Zeit, ja.
Ich muss aber eigentlich erwarten, dass FFmpeg
das für mich ausrechnet.
So, 25 FPS sind's angeblich nur.
Wie
krieg ich, wie krieg ich das raus
in FFmpeg?
Bei normalen, also ich weiß, dass man das bei normalen
Videos so rauskriegt, wie ich's
eben gemacht hab.
So, okay.
AV Packet GIF
FPS, ja.
Framerate.
Gibt's das vielleicht Frame, Framerate oder sowas?
Stream?
Frame? Average Framerate.
Okay.
Warte mal, wir haben ne R-Framerate
und wir haben ne
durchschnittliche Framerate.
Was ist das schon
wieder? Was?
Oh, Big Brain Time.
Jetzt hört's...
Was? Was will, was will
das von mir? Okay, wir
geben uns, wir geben das jetzt einfach mal aus.
Okay. Echt
kein Plan. Was da, was haben wir denn da
sonst noch hier? Und durchschnittliche,
durchschnittliche Framerate.
Okay.
Zeig her.
Ah ja.
Ah, okay, das passt. 25 FPS.
Beides zeigen sich das gleiche an. Also ist egal.
Zumindest bei diesem einen GIF
ist egal, was
ich nehme. Also, das ist
die Framerate von dem GIF. Das muss ich mir merken.
Ups.
Das muss ich mir merken, dass ich das nachher,
nachher richtig, richtig machen kann.
Okay, also. Das heißt,
wir wissen jetzt schon mal, wie man super schnell ein GIF malt.
Jutsch.
Da hat die Welt drauf gewartet.
So, und jetzt natürlich die
nächste Preisfrage. Wie krieg ich den
FPS-Counter?
Wie krieg ich den FPS-Counter hier oben,
hier oben hin?
Was das für ein Hotkey ist?
Control-K, Controls, also Control-K-C.
Control-K-C ist
ein- und auskommentieren.
Toggle.
Kekommentar, genau.
So.
Gut. Was hab ich jetzt gesagt,
müssen wir machen?
Boomer-Hirn wieder am Start.
Der Chat hat aber bestimmt aufgepasst.
FPS-Anzeige, korrekt.
Also.
Wie kriegen wir, wie kriegen wir, wie kriegen wir da jetzt
eine FPS-Anzeige gemalt?
So, das heißt,
FPS-Anzeige.
Draw Text? Aha.
Draw Text.
Uäh.
Ach du Scheiße, Microsoft,
was ist denn das wieder? Moment, was?
Was hast du?
Also.
Hast du eine Ahnung, ob es reicht,
bei einem Recapture von Google das Skript
in den HTML-Header zu packen und diesen dann
im Kontakt, also
vor dem Abschicken-Button oder was?
Ich hab Recapture noch, ehrlich gesagt,
nie verwendet. Keine Ahnung.
Leute, ich glaube, ich sollte
mal auf dem Preisschirm einen Recapture drauf machen.
Einfach um die Leute abzufacken.
Einfach so direkt,
direkt hier in die Mitte, so ein fettes Recapture.
Dass man dann ab und zu mal
Konten oder Fahrräder oder Zebrastreifen
oder so ausfüllen muss.
Nee, keine Ahnung.
Weiß ich nicht.
So, Draw Text. Okay.
Test.
Wir drawen auf.
Moment, was? Was zum?
ID write
Textformat?
Was?
Was will das von mir?
Null. Wir sagen einfach null, gibt's nicht.
Ähm.
Und jetzt muss ich
sagen, wo das Ganze
hingeschrieben wird.
Also oben links.
Keine Ahnung. 200, 200.
Das ist wieder richtig
abartig gemacht.
Der Brush. Moment, den haben wir doch
hier irgendwie.
Red oder Black?
Nee, wie hab ich denn?
Haben wir nicht irgendwo eine Farbe zum Farbemalen schon
gehabt? Wenn das nicht so unübersichtlich
eklig gemacht wäre, dann
Brush. Nee, haben wir nicht.
Okay. So, jetzt wird's wieder
Big Brain. Wie macht man den Kram?
Brush. Create.
Create. Solid
Color Brush. Wunderbar.
Color.
Warum gibt es eigentlich Color und
Color 4? Ich mein
Color, Color
sind hier so ganz normale Farben.
Okay. Was ist
Color 4? Ist genau
der gleiche Shit. Warum sollte ich denn
Warum gibt es Color 4 und Color?
Ach, Color mit und ohne Alpha.
Ah.
Verstehe. Nee, nee. Wollen wir nicht.
Color Black.
Ich kann auch nicht schreiben.
So. Und jetzt?
Das kackt ab. Das geht so
nicht. Das geht so garantiert nicht.
Das crasht jetzt. Kann bestimmt nicht 0
sein.
Das war ja klar.
Okay. Was muss da rein?
Da gibt's doch bestimmt auf GitHub
Wie hieß nochmal dieses komische Projekt, was ich hier
verwende für
DirectX
Sample. Whatis.
Genau.
Okay. Da brauch ich mal
Ich brauch da ein Beispiel.
Ich brauch da mal ein Beispiel für, wie das
aussieht. DrawText.
Super. Gibt's kein
Beispiel für. Perfekt.
Oder?
Gut. Dann brauch ich
DrawTextExample.
Zeig her.
Ah. Die gute Microsoft Hilfe. Jetzt weiß man,
sofort Bescheid.
ConstVeja.
Ja. String. Was muss denn da?
Was brauch ich denn da?
Ein
IDWriteTextFormat.
Wie
Funsterkram.
HowToDrawText.
Das muss alles äußerst
äußerst kompliziert sein.
Damit nicht irgendjemand auf die Idee
kommt, noch Text zu schreiben.
DrawText.
Okay. Jetzt zeige uns Herr Microsoft, wie das
geht. Textformat.
Wo gibt's das hier?
Ah. Das ist so obvious, dass Microsoft uns das
noch nicht mal zeigen muss. Verstehe.
Ach ne. Moment. Das ist T++.
CreateTextFormat.
Und dann. Okay.
Das macht mich fertig.
Dieses. Also Direct2D ist
eines der hässlichen, hässlichsten
Frameworks, mit denen ich jemals gemacht hab, Alter.
Ich hab da ein Video gesehen wegen
Programmieren. Ja. Das ist schonmal nice. Das ist.
Excellent.
Nice. So.
Wegen Programmieren lernen wir eine gute Sprache für den Anfang.
Welches denn? Das letzte, das mit
Algorithmen verstehen zusammen oder das ganz, ganz
alte?
Ich überlege die ganze Zeit, ob ich mir
Go anschauen soll
als Sprache oder bei
Python bleiben soll. Was denkst du? Ist sinnvoller.
Kommt drauf an, was du machen willst. Ist beides sinnvoll.
Also sowohl Go
als auch Python haben riesen Hype
die letzten Jahre über. Du machst mit keinem was falsch.
Es kommt drauf an, was du machen willst.
Du kannst
natürlich prinzipiell in fast
jeder Programmiersprache fast alles machen, aber
es gibt halt schon ein paar
Vorzüge. Also ich würde sagen,
wenn du was im Bereich, sagen wir mal so
AI, Machine Learning machen willst,
dann eher Python. Wenn du
was in Richtung
was weiß ich, wenn du mit irgendwelchen Cloud Tools
oder sowas zu tun hast, dann ist Go
eher das Richtige. Oder wenn du
möglichst
eigenständig lauffähige Anwendungen
haben willst, da ist Go auch wunderbar für.
Wenn es dir um die
Geschwindigkeit geht, dann
prinzipiell Go.
Allerdings Python, je nachdem was du für eine Library
nimmst, ist das auch schnell,
weil die Library dann in C programmiert ist.
Ist halt
die Frage, was du machen willst. Also das kann man
so pauschal nicht sagen.
Wir haben uns noch nichts überlegt.
Man kann mit Python auch ohne Probleme größere
Sachen machen. Wie gesagt, kommt, kommt, kommt.
Die ganze Home Assistant ist in Python
programmiert. Cringe,
Alter, wenn ich alles in Assembler schreibe.
Richtig cringe.
Ziemlich cringe Chat.
Lochkarten. Nee, Rechenschieber.
Komm jetzt.
Also wenn schon Oldschool,
dann richtig.
Dann Rechenschieber.
Aberkus.
Ja.
Hier, so programmieren die wahren Profis.
Ich will halt eine einfache
Syntax und eine halbwegs verständliche Ebenfalls
Möchte ich halt das programmieren.
Dann programmier weiter Python, weil
die Go-Syntax ist jetzt
Es ist die Go-Syntax.
Also syntaxmäßiger ist Python
ja meilenweit schöner als Go.
Und einfacher zu verstehen.
Also wenn es dir nur ums Lernen
und die Syntax geht, dann bleib
auf jeden Fall bei Python. Go ist
sicherlich da nicht das schönste.
Besten PHP und Java.
Man kann sich ja
viel streiten, aber dazu kann ich
einfach sagen,
No! God Please No!
No! No!
So nicht.
Gerade das in Kombination.
Wie finde ich
heraus, ob Fachinformatiker Systeme
Äh gar nicht.
Du guckst dir einfach die Unternehmen an, die einen Ausbildungsplatz
anbieten und suchst dir die raus, die dir am besten gefallen.
Scheiß drauf.
Im Prinzip
machts am Ende
wenn dir der Laden gefällt
nicht so viel unterschied von dem was du was du kannst ja und natürlich prinzipiell kann man sagen
klar die also die reine lehre wäre wenn du lieber sachen programmiert dann anwendungsentwickler wenn
du lieber netzwerk und administrator sachen machst dann fahre informatik systemintegration aber wie
gesagt je nach firma und anwendungsgebiet ist ist der übergang fließend echt gibt es das wirklich
leute naja gut jeder jeder jeder wieder wieder das richtig hält hat also die anlehnung von go
an c sind ja nun wirklich nicht sonderlich sonderlich groß wie wieder sachen deklariert
werden in welcher reihenfolge irgendwas geschrieben hat überhaupt nichts mit c zu tun was mit der
großen tags falsch ist das schlimmste ist schon mal dass die standardmäßig wollen dass man bei
einem if else die klammern auf die gleichen zeilen auf die gleiche zeile macht das schon mal das geht
schon mal das
will ich nicht das nervt mich jedes mal wenn ich sehe dann hast du so sachen wie error codes und
panik zusammen du hast keine du hast kein generic support er kommt jetzt irgendwann im jahr 2035
oder sommer dann hast du diese geschichte mit du kannst sachen mit wahr anlegen mit mit doppelpunkt
gleich für gleich initialisieren also ich finde hat schon so seine fallstricke c plus plus
na gut also c++ ist ja so dass das schlechte worauf wir uns alle darauf einigen können dass es
schlecht ist und alles alles ist besser als c++ sogar kobold ja klar warum ich du hast mit mehr
oder weniger allen halbwegs verbraucht verbreiteten sprachen eine chance muss halt gucken
also
Wenn du jetzt in einer Region bist, wo du bei jeder Stellenanzeige siehst, wir wollen PHP und Java haben, natürlich ist es dann sinnvoller, wenn du dir mal PHP und Java anguckst.
Aber man muss halt auch sagen, wenn du eine Sprache richtig gut kannst und vielleicht dir schon mal die ein oder anderen zusätzlichen Sprachen anguckt hast, du kommst in alles relativ schnell rein.
Wie gesagt, ich habe noch nie großartig Java, also direkt Java, JVM Sachen habe ich schon programmiert, aber ich habe noch nie Java programmiert, PHP habe ich schon mal ein bisschen gemacht, aber ich könnte mir das innerhalb von 1-2 Wochen so weit angucken, dass ich da ohne Probleme an Sachen mitprogrammieren könnte.
Aber ich habe gar keinen Bock, ich will gar kein Java lernen. Das kommt auf den Laden an, wo man ist. In die WhatsApp-Gruppe, natürlich. Snapchat wäre mir aber lieber, ehrlich gesagt. Oder gleich OnlyFans.
Ja, das stimmt. Die Prüfung, das siehst du allein schon bei den IHK-Prüfungen, dass da nicht großer Unterschied ist. Ja, es gibt einen Teil, den die machen und einen Teil, den die machen, aber der größte Teil der Prüfung ist die gleiche und macht kaum einen Unterschied.
Das würde ich so prinzipiell aussagen. Es gibt natürlich Ausnahmen, die die Regeln bestätigen. So etwas wie Rust ist halt wirklich massive Big Brain oder wenn dann einer anfängt mit so etwas Funktionalem, dann hört es halt erstmal auf.
So Erlang oder...
Oder noch schlimmer, Lisp, Alter. Wenn man möglichst viele Klammern... Also das hier, ich habe ja eh das Gefühl, das hier ist irgendwie ein gültiges Erlang-Programm so.
Das stimmt. Aber du wirst, sag mal so, solche Sachen wirst du in jeder Sprache mehr oder weniger finden, ja.
Quasi Strukturen, die mehr oder weniger dem Abbild, dem RAM entsprechen.
Kannst den Rust auch machen. Und der Rust-Style von so einem Struct ist nun wirklich nicht C-Style.
Echt, schaffen sie es jetzt langsam mal? Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Was mir bei Go, was mich bei Go nervt, ist, dass Go mir sagen will, was ich machen soll.
Unused Imports, Unused Variable. Fuckt mich mega ab.
Manchmal will ich einfach was einbinden, ausprobieren, mal kurz was auskommentieren, gucken, ob es dann anders funktioniert.
Und jedes Mal muss ich den Scheiß löschen und umkopieren, weil Go der Meinung ist, nein, nein, nein, nein, du darfst das jetzt nicht machen, weil Unused Import.
Nein, nein, das geht jetzt nicht. Du hast die Variable auskommentiert. Nein, nein, Unused Variable, das geht nicht.
Das nervt mich.
Zu mir wurde mal gesagt...
Was? Moment, Moment, was?
Ich rede heute ein bisschen zu schnell beim Lesen irgendwie.
Zu mir wurde mal gesagt, wer ein Anwendungsentwickler...
Denn einem Entwickler traut man eher Systemersachen zu als andersrum.
Da kennst du aber die meisten Entwickler bei uns nicht.
Denen würde ich mir alles zutrauen, aber bloß keine System- oder Netzwerkgeschichten.
Hab ich euch schon von dem... Ja, hab ich euch.
Ich hab euch von dem Anwendungsentwickler erzählt, der wollte...
...dass ich in den Key-Value-Store...
...zwei Values hinterlege, oder? Für einen Key.
Und der es nicht eingesehen hat, dass ich ihm erklärt hab, dass es nicht funktioniert.
Ja, also, für alle, die es nicht mitgekriegt haben, es hat bei uns jemand angefragt, ob ich...
...in einen Key-Value-Store für ihn ein paar Werte, also ein paar Werte updaten kann.
Oder neue Werte reinschreiben kann.
Sag ich, okay, ja, klar, kein Problem, was willst du haben?
Und da meinte er bei mir so, ja, er will Key A, B, C...
...und bei jedem müssen dann halt zwei Werte rein.
Ich hab gesagt, äh...
...das ist ein Key-Value-Store.
Es gibt einen Key und einen Value dazu.
Das funktioniert so nicht.
Was ich machen kann, ist, ich kann da eine JSON-Array reinschreiben...
...und du passt dann selbst deine zwei Values raus.
Nein, das will ich nicht. Ich will zwei Werte zurückbekommen.
Das geht aber nicht.
Du kannst zu einem Key nur ein Value speichern.
Oder ein Text, beziehungsweise in dem Fall sogar.
Es ist sogar nur Text-Text-only.
Also, das geht nicht.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Ich meine, ich kann dir die Keys durchnummerieren.
Ich kann dir die Keys durchnummerieren.
A1, A2 und dann werde...
Nein, ich will zwei Werte haben.
Ich hab's dann irgendwann aufgegeben.
Ich hab dann gesagt, entweder schreibe ich ein JSON-Array rein...
...oder irgendwas oder gar nichts.
Oder ein CSV rein, genau.
Alles möglich.
Du kannst auch ein YAML reinschreiben.
Oder ein TOML.
Oder ein INI-File.
Du kannst alles, solange es Text ist, reinschreiben.
Kratz.
Easy.
Abschlussprüfung oder hast du auch deine mündliche Abschlussprüfung gemacht schon?
Also, bist du jetzt komplett durch?
Also, hast du quasi...
Bist du seit heute offiziell fachinformatische Anwendungsentwicklung?
Oder hast du nur die schriftliche Prüfung geschafft?
Also, Rust ist richtig Big Brain.
Ich verstehe, was OOP ist, aber was ist eigentlich funktionale Programmierung?
Funktionale Programmierung ist für alle Mathe-Studenten oder Mathe-Professoren,
die Big Brain-Software programmieren wollen.
Ja, ist echt der Wahnsinn.
So, also, machen wir mal weiter.
Wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Wie funktioniert das jetzt hier mit dem Text?
Write Factory?
Was zum Geier?
Was muss ich machen, dass ich Text ausgeben kann?
Das kann doch nicht so schwierig sein.
Factory.
Irgendwas mit Factory.
Wie habe ich denn hier Factories erstellt?
Hier, Create Factory.
Alles klar, mache ich jetzt.
Das muss ich aber nur einmal erstellen.
Das hier muss ich auch nur einmal erstellen.
Sonst Memory-Leak am Start.
Okay, ähm, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Write Factory.
Ähm, Create.
Write, ne, äh, ach du Scheiße.
Sorry, Write Factory.
Hier, Factory.
Create.
Ne, ach du große Kacke, wie geht das?
Create?
Nee.
Ich habe es nicht.
Meine Güte, wie habe ich das denn da oben nochmal gemacht?
Factory.
Ist ja fast wie in Java.
So, so habe ich die eine hier erstellt.
Und wie, wie, okay, okay.
Also, so, so konnte man das eine erstellen.
Und wie geht das jetzt hier?
Create.
Nee.
Factory.
Eins?
Nee.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert.
Ich will einfach Text schreiben, Alter.
Please.
Lass mich doch einfach nur Text hinschreiben, Microsoft.
Ach, komm.
Komm mal hier.
Da, so, so.
Ah.
Welches Programm?
Das hier, du meinst die IDE?
Das ist Rider.
Das ist die Jetbrains C-Sharp IDE.
Was lustig ist, dass man Java IDE hat für C-Sharp zu programmieren.
Aber warum?
Warum nicht, ja?
Factory.
Okay.
Bam.
Geht das jetzt?
Was?
Factory Type?
Was will der denn von mir haben?
Okay.
Factory Type.
Einfach, einfach so.
Wir, wir, wir probieren das jetzt einfach, einfach aus.
Was mich ja auch immer übelst verwirrt bei diesem DirectX-Zeug.
Warum gibt es, warum gibt es Factory 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7?
Ich meine, klar, ich weiß, die haben mit Factory angefangen und irgendwann neue Funktionen hinzugefügt.
Aber das ist so hardcore Unübersichtlung.
Unübersichtlich.
Ist Rider Visual Studio vorzuziehen?
Ist ein bisschen Geschmackssache.
Ich verwende Rider, weil ich hauptsächlich unter Linux programmiere.
Und da gibt es halt nur Rider als IDE.
Und.
Der Chat hat das letzte Mal gemeint, nimm doch einfach Rider auch unter Windows.
Hab ich Rider auch unter Windows.
Ansonsten habe ich unter Windows eigentlich immer Visual Studio verwendet.
So.
Ride Factory.
Moment, Moment.
Das war es ja noch nicht.
Das war es ja nicht.
Jetzt muss ich, jetzt muss ich noch anlegen, ein Textformat anlegen.
Okay.
Create.
Textformat.
Font Family Name.
Oh ne.
Areal.
Bam.
Da weiß ich auf jeden Fall, dass es drauf.
Font Size 30.
Dass man das auch ordentlich sieht.
Äh, Moment.
Das ist kein String.
30.
So.
Textformat.
Was man dafür, was man das, da muss ich ja echt das Bein ausreißen, dass man hier Text ausgeben darf.
So, meint ihr es funktioniert jetzt, dass jetzt oben links in der Ecke Test steht?
Ich, ich habe so meine Zweifel, dass das funktioniert.
Aber wir werden es, wir werden es gleich sehen.
Tatsächlich funktioniert.
Guck mal da.
Test.
Bam.
Funktioniert.
Tatsächlich.
Hätte nicht gedacht.
Gut.
Weiter.
Dann muss ich, muss ich diesen ganzen Mist hier in der, in der Schleife machen und jetzt
kann ich die FPS ausgeben.
Jetzt kann ich die FPS ausgeben.
Die muss, das muss übrigens umgedreht sein so.
Achso.
Cool String.
Ja.
So und jetzt sollte ich die FPS da oben drinne stehen haben.
Oh.
Guck mal da.
Funktioniert aber nicht.
Warum nicht?
Leute, ich glaube ich habe das übelste Memory Leak.
Ach nee, das kann ja nicht funktionieren.
Ich zähle, ich zähle ja hier hoch.
Ich zähle ja, ist ja Schwachsinn.
Funktioniert ja so gar nicht, was, was ich da mache.
Das funktioniert überhaupt nicht.
Äh, das da darf ich quasi nur hier drinnen machen.
Aber dann überschreibt es jedes Mal, ne?
Oder?
Ich muss das zwischenspeichern.
Ja nee, das ist Mist.
Das funktioniert so nicht.
Leute, ich muss mal kurz checken.
Ob ich nicht irgendwie super hardcore Memory Leak am Start habe.
Ich habe das Gefühl irgendwie, dass das ziemlich hart Memory Leak gerade.
Warte mal.
Gucken wir mal kurz in Visual Studio rein.
Ob das Memory Leak.
Nee.
Gar nicht mal so.
Also ein bisschen Memory Leak.
Aber wir können auch mal warten, bis, bis, bis sich das eingependelt hat.
Vielleicht.
Also ich würde sagen, ein bisschen Memory Leaken tut's.
Haha.
Aber mal gucken.
Vielleicht pendelt sich das auch ein.
Nee, es scheint nicht Memory zu leaken.
Das muss sich einfach warmlaufen.
Okay, wunderbar.
Ich habe keine Memory Leaks produziert.
Schon mal nice.
Mach rot.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Wo siehst du den Leakprinzip?
Na ja, da.
Du siehst neben den RAM-Verbrauch.
Und wenn der RAM-Verbrauch hat ein...
Ich zeig's dir mal.
Moment.
Memory Leak.
Ach, Moment.
Dann funktioniert das ja nicht.
Pass mal auf.
Memory Leak.
Du wirst direkt sehen, dass es Memory Leak.
Fällt dir was auf?
Fünf Gigabyte RAM-Verbrauch.
Ich meine, das ist jetzt ein äußerst offensichtliches, ja?
Oftmals sind die Dinger deutlich subtiler und man sieht die nicht so, nicht so wirklich.
Übrigens auch wieder bester Variablen-Namen natürlich hier am Start.
Okay, wir haben keinen Memory Leak.
Paprizierter.
Das ist doch schon mal nice.
Okay, was sollen wir?
Wir sollen den Text...
Den Text rot machen.
Das mache ich.
Color.
Red.
Oh, guck mal.
Krass, guck...
Ryder ist echt big Brain.
Seht ihr das?
Ryder ist richtig big Brain.
Er zeigt sogar die Farbe unten drunter an, welches genau ist, welcher Ton.
Das ist wirklich cool.
Cool gemacht.
Okay, das funktioniert nicht so, wie ich mir das gedacht habe.
Ich muss...
Okay.
Ich komm raus.
Ich bin fertig.
Das im оноom.
Ja, ich hab's year.
Da kommt eins.
Leider.
Das ist mein...
Ich muss noch irgendwie den Counter
zwischenspeichern.
Äh, Temp.
Als beste Vernahmung aller Zeiten
wieder am Start.
Da weißt du Bescheid.
Du weißt sofort, was Sache ist.
Oh, was jetzt?
Temp ist
already defined. Anzeige
ist raus. Pass mal auf,
Temp 2.
Ah, yes.
Guck mal da.
Huge FPS Counter.
Monospace Font, da hast du recht.
Areal zackt. Was ist denn ein
Monospace Font? Kann man
Windows überreden, dass er
Monospace macht, wenn man das so angibt?
Nee, oder?
Was passiert denn eigentlich, wenn ich
Font Family weglasse? Kackt's dann ab?
Nö,
dann macht er Default.
Du bist der Einzige, der keinen Ton hat, ja?
Consolers.
Ist das Standard
nicht installiert?
Ah, jetzt. Hier, guck mal.
Exquisite.
Der kommt mit dem V-Sync ein bisschen
durcheinander. Okay, hier.
High Performance
GIF
Player. Okay.
Also das mit FPS
funktioniert. Das ist übrigens ein ziemlich schlechter
FPS Counter. Das stimmt überhaupt
nicht. Wenn das hier beispielsweise länger
braucht,
eigentlich müsste
ich sagen, ich nehme
die Anzahl geteilt
durch
die Sekunden oder sowas.
Nee, Moment. Sekunden durch die Anzahl?
Anzahl durch Sekunden? Moment, ich bin jetzt
verwirrt. Nee, Anzahl
durch Sekunden.
Dann macht er halt ein Double draus, meinetwegen,
wenn es hier lieber ist.
Ah, nee, das geht nicht.
Dann wird Temp 2 jetzt
ein Double. Oh, das ist so
wahnsinnig hübscher
Code
hier. Gibt's nix.
Best Practice
komplett.
Alles Best Practice?
Okay, meine Logik ist nicht richtig.
Meine Logik
ist auf jeden Fall nicht korrekt.
Was mach ich? Was mach ich? Verkehrt?
FPS durch gesamte
Sekunden.
Ah,
For Restart. Tatsächlich. Ja,
null.
Falsch rum. Okay.
Das funktioniert.
Der
Zeilenumbruch nur.
Das funktioniert.
realistischer alles klar so das ist das ist das ist mega hässlich wie konnte man den kram noch
mal runden wobei das war das ist so hässlich dann schadet nichts wenn es jetzt auch noch ein
bisschen hässlicher wird easy life genau okay wunderbar jetzt haben wir unseren fps counter
eigentlich das unsinnigste aller zeiten zumal das wahrscheinlich an der stelle auch wieder weg muss
wie bin ja wie sind wir da jetzt drauf gekommen das ist eigentlich überhaupt nicht das was ich
machen wollte heute oder wahrscheinlich nicht also wie sie ausgeschaltet und fps counter super
dass das das hat die welt das hat die welt gebraucht vielleicht sollten wir mal anfangen
das ordentlich zu machen sonst blickt doch da echt keine saume durch war kurz runter auf 60
fps ob das funktioniert ach so er oder auf 30 wenn du mit warum auf 30 16 millisekunden
sind eigentlich 60 fps okay ich ich ich ich ich gucke nicht wie lange der kram hier oben dauert
aber da kann er nicht so lange dauern sind sind der restliche kauf ich kann mir nicht vorstellen
dass er 16 millisekunden verballert das ist dann könnte dann würde er nicht rennen damit mit 1000
fps sonst
minute
It's just a long flight
es ist doch 60 60 millisekunden oder ja und 32是 Age
wirklich mane es aber die low spd possessive ist 축 folder lächeln bis 26
es ist auch 60 fps 60 millisekunden oder
hier Und dann sind das 16fps
das funktioniert halbwegs das was ich hier was ich hier machen funktioniert nicht warum muss ich das doppelt so schnell machen dass es das Schaft die Stopwatch zählt nicht wenn der threat líbt das ist eine wirklich gute frage ? ich habe keine Ahnung wenn ich ehrlich bin zählt die Stopwatch zählt nicht wenn der threat líbt Das ist eine wirklich gute Frage ich habe keine Ahnung wenn ich ehrlich bin zählt die stopwatch zählt nicht wenn der thrat líbt das zur vara trink corpo aus.
Zählt die Stopwatch nicht, wenn er Threats liebt?
Das würde es zumindest teilweise erklären.
Zählt weiter.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, warum das hier nicht funktioniert.
Aber macht auch keinen Unterschied.
Weil eigentlich müssen wir das eh jetzt aufräumen.
Stack Overflow wieder am Start.
Stack Overflow, Stack Overflow am Start.
Aha.
Alles klar.
Macht's nicht.
Task Delay könnte ich genauso gut verwenden.
Das ist mega hässlich.
Das lasse ich eh nicht so.
Das müssen wir jetzt langsam mal anfangen ordentlich zu machen.
Weiß nicht, ob ich da heute die Brain-Kapazität dafür habe, das ordentlich zu machen.
Also lass mal überlegen.
Wir haben einen FPS-Counter.
Ist schon mal wunderbar.
Du hast recht.
Aber hier eigentlich ist das bescheuert.
Eigentlich müsste ich hier die Stopwatch machen.
Und jedes Mal gucken, wie lange der Durchlauf braucht.
Und das dann abziehen von dem, was ich sleepe.
Wie lange braucht denn das Ganze hier?
So ein Schleifendurchlauf.
Keine Ahnung.
Check.
Wie lange braucht das denn so?
Schaut mal her.
Das wird nicht lange sein.
Sind das drei Millisekunden?
Nee.
Ach du Scheiße.
Was ist das?
Floated.
What?
30?
Warum dauert das denn so lang?
Das kann doch gar nicht sein.
Ach so.
Ah, hier.
Restart.
Lull.
Ah, das sieht schon besser aus.
Debugger.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Wobei ich nicht glaube, dass das einen großen Unterschied machen wird.
Was?
Ein bisschen.
Wo ist da meine...
Mein Denkfehler mit dem Sleep?
Kann das sein, dass das Sleep einfach nicht genau...
Doch, das müsste genau genug sein.
Okay, ich habe keine Ahnung, woran das liegt.
Aber drei Millisekunden sind trotzdem ganz schön lang.
Ich meine, der decodet den Kram.
Hm.
Sleep ich hier noch irgendwo anders?
Nee.
Ja, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube, meine FPS-Berechnung stimmt nicht.
Ich glaube, meine FPS-Berechnung ist einfach trash.
As fuck.
Aber eigentlich will ich mich damit jetzt gar nicht aufhalten.
Denn, das bleibt eh nicht so.
Sondern wir müssen das jetzt mal langsam anfangen, ein bisschen ordentlich zu machen.
Weil ich blicke nicht mehr durch.
Könntest du das encoden nicht machen, während du das decoden?
Ich encode nix.
Ich könnte das multithreaden nicht machen.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass das irgendwie eine riesen Auswirkung hat.
Weil das DirectX-Zeug ist so schnell gemalt.
Ob ich da vom Multithreading groß profitiere?
Keine Ahnung.
So, wir müssen es jetzt mal ein bisschen schöner machen.
Ich muss mal kurz in mich gehen, ob ich da heute Abend noch genug Brain für habe oder nicht.
Wir müssen eigentlich auch noch einstellen, dass man das resizen kann.
Multithreaded Render Target.
Das wäre in dem Fall kein Problem.
Hm.
Weil ich es ja nach wie vor nur aus einem Tablet machen würde.
Also ich würde das ja nur in einem Tablet rendern.
Aber ich würde halt das Bild halt ab und zu mal updaten, was gerendert wird.
Nee, das bringt glaube ich nix.
So, also wir müssen das jetzt irgendwie ein bisschen ordentlich machen.
Ich bin gerade am überlegen, ob ich das heute Big Brain-technisch mache oder nicht.
Nee.
Aber warum brauche ich denn drei?
Ich meine, drei Millisekunden ist ganz schön lang.
Nein, drei Millisekunden ist viel.
Was braucht denn hier die drei Millisekunden?
Zeig mal her.
Ich mache das gerade mal wieder rein.
Was braucht denn hier eigentlich die drei Millisekunden?
Es liegt nicht daran, dass es liegt daran.
Was verbraucht denn hier eigentlich die drei Millisekunden, dass die Code vom GIF?
Ja, ja, dass die Code vom GIF.
Der Task läuft ja permanent.
Das macht nichts.
Dass die Code vom GIF braucht drei Millisekunden.
Aber warum?
Warum braucht das die Code vom GIF drei Millisekunden?
Ich meine, es ist ziemlich, ziemlich bescheuert, wie ich es mache, ne?
Ich lese Frame by Frame von der Platte, decode das dann.
Das ist das eigentliche Problem.
Dass die Code ist... Ich könnte wetten, dass die Code ist nicht das Problem.
Sondern das Einlesen von der Platte ist das Problem.
Nee.
Es ist ernsthaft, dass die Code was drei Millisekunden braucht.
Das hätte ich im Leben nicht gemacht.
Das hätte ich im Leben nicht gedacht, dass man drei Millisekunden braucht, um einen GIF-Frame zu decoden.
Krass.
Da kann ich aber dann nicht viel dran ändern.
Also das hier ist wirklich das, was die Zeit frisst.
GIF decoden.
Ja gut, ach, das machst du nix.
Dann ist das halt so.
Da kann ich, da kann ich nichts dran ändern.
Alter, meine Variablen-Benahmung.
Es ist so schlecht.
Es ist so hässlich.
Das darfst du keinem zeigen.
Das werde ich definitiv nicht auf Shithub posten.
Dafür musst du dich ja schämen.
GIF in den RAM laden.
Doch, doch, geht.
Aber bringt nix.
FFmpeg Overhead.
Warum sollte FFmpeg Overhead sein?
Du brauchst irgendwas, was dein GIF decodet.
In dem Fall ist es halt FFmpeg.
Also ich würde jetzt eine notwendige Komponente nicht unbedingt Overhead nennen.
Es wird jedes Bild immer wieder neu decodet.
Ja, aber das macht also nichts.
Das Decoden ist wirklich das Problem.
Klar, ich könnte mir das GIF einmal merken.
Aber das ist egal.
Das macht jetzt nichts.
Drei Millisekunden sind nicht wild.
Aber ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass das Decoden eines einzelnen Low Res GIF Bildes drei Millisekunden braucht.
Na ja, gut.
Ist dann halt so.
Immer noch, immer noch besser.
Immer noch schneller als das hier.
Guckt euch das mal an. Immer noch schneller als das hier.
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Das ist ein lahmes Fuck.
Das sind drei Sekunden, nicht drei Millisekunden.
Probier es mal mit dem GIF.
Mach ich.
Ich kann das doch einfach.
Dann ist es einfacher für mich.
Ich kann das hier oben resetten.
So.
Braucht wirklich.
Braucht wirklich drei Sekunden.
Äh, drei Millisekunden.
Was ist denn dieses GIF hier?
Um das mal auszuprobieren mit...
Wo liegt denn das?
Champing.
Wo liegt das Champing GIF?
Weiß ich doch jetzt nicht.
Oh, könnte... Memes 2 vielleicht?
Nee.
Moment, wo liegt denn dieses komische Programm?
Die sagen irgendwo Web Application 11.
Wo liegt die denn?
Hier, Web Application 11.
Web Application 11.
Alles klar.
www.root.content
Da ist es.
So, wo...
Sieht jemand?
Ist es das?
Das ist es.
Das wollen wir haben.
GIF.
Mal gucken, wie lange das braucht.
Beste Namen, das ist Absicht,
dass die nicht kollidieren.
Nö.
Das ist ein Ticken langsamer noch.
Aber trotzdem.
Warum ist das überhaupt so langsam?
Vier Sekunden zum Sieg hauen von einem GIF.
Ja, das ist halt
High Res, High Res, High IQ
GIF.
Braucht halt ein bisschen.
Aber der Thread Sleep ist in dem Fall egal.
Ich meine, ich mache
Thread Sleep mal weg,
aber ich resette die Stopwatch hier oben.
Das sollte überhaupt keinen Unterschied machen.
Wow.
Da bist du ja schlecht bei.
Nope Champ.
Ist tatsächlich schneller.
Warum?
Warum ist das schneller?
Das macht doch überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Ich restate
das hier oben.
Und da ist es null.
Und das ist doch egal, ob ich da unten sleep oder nicht.
Ich sleep jetzt mal,
keine Ahnung, 800.
Ne.
What?
Ich blick nicht mehr durch.
Was hat das?
Warum hat das überhaupt Einfluss da drauf?
Ich habe irgendwo was total bescheuert
programmiert.
Das kann überhaupt nicht sein.
Stopwatch.
Hier wird die restartet.
Ich nenn die mal gescheit.
Und hier wird die Zeit ausgegeben.
Hä?
Ich mach mal einen Stop vorher.
Ich bin hochgradig
verwirrt.
Was das da
mit dem Rest zu tun haben soll.
Äußerst verwirrt.
Was das eine mit dem anderen
zu tun haben soll.
Ich mein.
Restart
und ausgeben.
Da hat doch unten
sleep unten nichts mit zu tun.
Und selbst wenn jetzt da
Context Switching, bla, was auch immer.
Ich mach es ja hier in diesem Schleifendurchlauf.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube wir scheißen einfach
Optimierung auf die Optimierung
hier in diesem Ding.
Ich mach das dann mal ordentlich.
Dann kann man nämlich auch verstehen.
Was ich da programmiert habe.
Das ist aber nicht sehr clean.
Ne.
Das ist der neue Trend.
Nach Clean Code kommt Trash Code.
Weil die Leute erkannt haben,
Clean Code dauert zu lang.
Und es ist wichtig, dass man Prototypen
hat.
Das heißt, ab jetzt werde ich auf jedem Talk,
auf jeder Konferenz, wo ich hingehe und meine Talks halte,
werde ich Trash Code propagieren.
Agile Trash Code.
So machen wir das.
Demnächst könnt ihr
Tickets gewinnen
im Stream.
Das Genie beherrscht das, sag ich auch immer.
Genauso wie mein Desktop.
Die Leute sagen immer, das ist unaufgeräumt,
da blickt keiner durch.
Aber in Wirklichkeit muss man einfach nur suchen können
wo was ist, dann findet man auch alles sofort.
Ja, ist schon.
Ich würde sagen, es ist auf jeden Fall
Best Practice
mein Code.
Gerade vor allem
mit Sicherheit auch DirectX
Best Practice.
Es best praktiziert ohne Ende hier.
Komplettes
Best Practice aus dem ITIL Buch.
Einer hat mit dem anderen
überhaupt gar nichts zu tun, aber egal.
Safe ist das. Safe.
Safe und
Wie heißt dieses andere
agile Zeug?
Ach, ich habe schon wieder vergessen,
was auch gerade voll im Trend ist.
Safe und
Ach, ich kann mir das alles nicht merken.
Blockchain.
Nein, nein, nein.
Du kannst Blockchain bei fast allem
sagen, aber da passt es nicht.
Nein, nein, nein. Safe.
Safe Agile.
Was ich meine ist das hier.
Agile Framework.
Wie heißt
die Konkurrenz zu Safe?
Auch gerade total angesagt.
Aber ich will mich mit diesem Kram gar nicht beschäftigen hier.
No.
We're champing.
Okay, gibt es irgendwas Sinnvolles, was wir jetzt noch machen können?
Ich muss mal ein bisschen mein Hirn
zusammenhalten gerade.
Wir haben ja heute im Prinzip nichts gemacht, außer einen hässlichen
FPS Counter eingebaut.
Der Skiff ist
viel zu langsam.
400 FPS?
Das ist doch nichts.
Da geht mehr.
Ich muss das doch multithreaded machen, glaube ich.
Ich glaube,
wir müssen das doch in Zukunft
multithreaded machen.
Wir müssen das doch multithreaded machen.
Aber schneller decoden wird er dadurch auch nicht.
Aber schneller decoden wird er dadurch
auch nicht.
Das bringt eigentlich gar nichts.
Also das decoden ist einfach zu langsam.
Aber da kann ich nichts dran ändern.
Das ist halt FFM Pack.
Vielleicht geht das einfach nicht schneller.
Beim anderen GIF-Decoder ist das auch nicht schneller.
Außerdem will ich keinen anderen GIF-Decoder verwenden,
weil ich will damit ja vielleicht auch
andere Videoformate decoden,
anstatt nur GIF.
Nutzt direkt OpenGL,
das eine hat doch mit dem anderen gar nichts zu tun.
Das Rendern ist nicht das Langsame.
Das GIF-Decoden ist das Langsame.
Das Rendern braucht, keine Ahnung,
ein paar Nanosekunden oder so.
So, aber ich glaube,
ich sollte anfangen, das mal ein bisschen ordentlicher zu machen.
Weil ich blicke nicht mal durch.
Ich würde sagen, Proof of Concept,
es funktioniert.
Aber
jetzt
ist es vorbei.
Wir machen eine
Form für den Player.
Wir brauchen ein
Video-Decoder.
Klasse, brauchen wir.
Dann habe ich irgendwo
schon was
für meine RGB
Video-Frames angelegt gehabt.
Video-Frame? Ne.
Oder habe ich da überhaupt eine Klasse für?
Ich blicke nicht mal durch,
Leute.
Es ist einfach vorbei.
Es ist komplett,
komplett RIP.
Frame.
Hier.
Data.
Ach ne, ich schreibe das Data direkt.
Ja, das ist ein bisschen,
das ist äußerst,
eklig.
Okay, wir brauchen noch eine eigene Klasse
für den Video.
Video-Frame.
RGB.
Zeug.
Mal kurz, lass mal kurz in mich gehen.
Wie könnte man das gut kapseln?
So ein
eindecodetes GIF.
Also, auf jeden Fall
unsafe, weil FFmpeg.
Anders funktioniert es nicht.
So, wir
brauchen, Alter.
Ich kann nicht schreiben, Leute. Es ist vorbei.
Ich glaube, ich sollte aufhören.
Ich kann nicht mehr schreiben.
Wir brauchen hier, würde ich sagen,
einen
RAW
FFmpeg-Frame.
Wo wir dann
Zeug mitmachen.
So, also was müssen wir von so einem
Video-Frame, also von so einem decodeten GIF,
von einem einzelnen decodeten
Bild aus der GIF-Animation wissen?
Wir müssen wissen, wie breit das Ganze
ist.
Also sagen wir mal, irgendwie breit. Breite
brauchen wir. Wir brauchen,
irgendwie, Höhe.
So, dann brauchen wir noch,
was gibt's denn da sonst noch?
Moin, Jonathan, DVD,
POG. Wir brauchen
Data. Data brauchen wir.
Data und, was benutzen
wir sonst noch vom Frame?
Äh, Linesize.
Okay, das nennen wir einfach so.
Was ist denn das, ein Int?
Oder, was ist Linesize?
Int. Öffnende
Klammer haben keine eigene Zeile verdient. Doch.
Sonst ist das viel zu eklig.
Leute,
Linesize oder Linesize?
Linesize, so, hä?
So, okay, was brauchen so ein Frame
noch? Äh, Data.
Data ist
ein was? Ein Int? Int-Pointer,
glaub ich.
Data. Byte.
Byte-Pointer hier.
Aber da, so was.
Data.
Best Practice, genau.
Chat, was ist los?
Was ist los? Warum
ist das so sadge?
Warum nicht white happy?
Warum white sadge?
Was stimmt hier nicht?
Wegen der Klammer!
Nee.
Das ist doch nicht sadge.
Das ist genau umgedreht.
Sadge ist es, wenn man die Klammer auf die eigene Zeile
macht.
So ist das eigentlich ziemlich poggers.
Okay, wollen wir eine Umfrage machen?
So, wir machen eine Umfrage.
Mal gucken, ob ich das hier auf die Reihe krieg
nebenbei.
Frage.
Klammer auf gleicher
Zeile
vom if
oder
auf gleicher Zeile
äh
wir machen das anders. Klammer
auf gleicher Zeile
auf
Zeile
runter.
So. Dauer.
Umfrage. Eine Minute. Bam.
Einfach Python programmieren. Ja.
Easy.
So, also, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Also, ich bin eindeutig für Zeile drunter.
Aber jeder wie er will.
Wenn der Neue
die Klammer in der gleichen Zeile macht,
so sieht's aus.
Direkt die Abmahnung mitgeschickt.
Korrekt.
Aber es kann jeder machen,
was er will.
Der Chat ist sich wieder nicht einig.
Funktionszeile drunter,
if selbe Zeile. Oh, ich seh, es gibt auch Leute,
die Kombinationen aus beidem verwenden.
Ich mach eigentlich immer
Zeile drunter.
Ich finde, man sollte auch ein bisschen
danach gucken, was der Hersteller-
Guide ist für die jeweilige Sprache.
In C-Sharp ist es auf jeden Fall
Zeile drunter.
Es gibt aber andere Sprachen wie
Go, da ist es richtig hässlich.
Und ist immer gleiche Zeile.
Es ist aber ziemlich
50-50.
Also kaum, kaum ein Unterschied dazwischen.
So, jetzt ist die nächste Umfrage.
Die wir machen konnten, ist eigentlich gleich noch.
Variablen-Namen.
Pascal-Case,
Camel-Case,
Kebab-Case. Wisst ihr,
Kebab-Case ist das Beste, oder?
Kebab-Case.
Snake-Case.
Pascal-Case.
Binnen-Majuskel.
Meine ich. Falls ihr das mehr sagt.
Alles klar.
Was le...
Was zum Geier lädt das bitteschön da?
Was ist das überhaupt für...
Was ist das überhaupt für eine Seite?
C2.com
Was sagt der Typ da eigentlich?
Der sagt Jesus, sagt der.
Jesus sagt der.
Jetzt.
Das soll Jesus heißen.
Das versteht bloß kein Mensch.
Das verstehen doch nicht mal Spanier.
Der sagt aber nicht Jesus, weil Jesus,
sondern weil der Moderator aus der Sendung Jesus heißt.
Falls jemand mal das Original
gesehen hat.
Leute, ich kann nicht mal denken.
Das war keine gute Idee,
dass ich Big Brain Programming
Stream machen wollte heute Abend.
Ich kann nicht mal denken, Leute.
Es ist vorbei.
Wir müssen uns vertagen.
Mein Brain macht heute
nicht mehr mit.
Wir gucken jetzt noch.
Jetzt noch Barbecue Pit Boys.
Ich würde sagen, wir gucken als erstes
und zwar das Video an.
Vom Meister höchstpersönlich.
To protect your Linux Server from
Hackers.
From Hackermans.
Ich gebe natürlich meinen Senf zu,
ob ich die Sachen auch so sehe oder nicht,
aber mal gucken, was er sagt.
Schauen wir mal.
So, mal kurz Musik ausmachen.
So.
Man kann sich über alles streiten,
ehrlich gesagt.
Auch diese Sache mit
keinem Root-User benutzen und sowas
ist schon sinnvoll,
aber ob man das jetzt so als
generelle Regel
sagen sollte,
ja, wüsste ich jetzt auch nicht.
SSH-Port wechseln mache ich
tatsächlich so gut wie nie.
Ah,
Sick Set.
ja,
das stimmt schon.
Jetzt mal unabhängig davon,
ob das irgendwelche Security-Gruppen sind,
Geschichten sind oder nicht,
es gibt so ein paar Gurus
in vielen Programmiersprachen
oder in vielen Bereichen,
wenn die irgendwas sagen und irgendeiner ist der Meinung,
das ist jetzt Best Practice, dann muss das sein.
Ja, guck mal an, wie viele
Leute es gibt, die dir erzählen
wollen, sie sind die einzigen, die wissen,
wie man agile Projekte macht.
Oder das schlimmste,
das schlimmste Negativ-Beispiel,
was mir dazu einfällt, ist,
ich hab mal vor ein paar Jahren
von irgend so einem Ober-Rubi
Programmierer
Guru
mal einen
Talk gesehen von einer Konferenz
und ich glaube, ich hab das schon mal erzählt
und er hat allen Ernstes,
da hat er erzählt,
ja hier, das ist ein Codesmell
und das ist ein Codesmell, das war so sein Lieblingswort
und dann hat er allen Ernstes
behauptet, dass jede
Ruby-Methode, die länger
ist als eine Zeile,
ein Codesmell ist.
Und da hab ich mir auch gedacht, alter,
jetzt drehen sie echt
am Rad, ja?
Wie sieht denn das bei dem aus?
Hat der denn irgendwie
Nesting-Levels oder was?
Mehr als eine Zeile ist bloat
oder was? Was ist das erste Kommentar?
Was
denn das da?
Den guck ich auch ab und zu mal,
wenn es irgendwas interessantes gibt.
Solche Ruby-Meinung kenn ich in Real auch.
Ja, Ruby-Leute sind da teilweise,
wie gesagt, neben C-Sharp ist Ruby meine absolut
Lieblingssprache, leider in letzter Zeit ein bisschen
so unter die Räder gekommen, aber
da wird vieles, also gerade im Ruby-Umfeld
wird vieles so voll religiös
gebetet schon, wie man was programmieren
muss. Dabei ist Ruby eine Sprache,
die lässt so mehr oder weniger fast alles,
alles zu. Was ist der zweite Kommentar?
Better Advice. Turn your screen
brightness way down.
Hehehe. Alter, Hacker
haben immer Sonnenbrillen auf und dann haben sie es schwierig,
den Bildschirm zu lesen. Ja, so sieht's aus.
Das wissen wir natürlich. Und die haben
auch immer Matrix-Bildschirmschoner laufen. Immer.
Wenn ihr
mal jemanden seht, der
sagt, er ist Hacker und hat keinen
Matrix-Bildschirmschoner laufen, dann wisst ihr
gleich, er erzählt Mist.
C-Matrix-Bestiav. Wo wir gerade dabei sind,
ich muss mal kurz meine 4M anmachen.
Wir machen die Qt4M an.
Qt4M. Die kriegt
zu wenig Aufmerksamkeit
in letzter Zeit.
So, beste. Und jetzt C-Matrix.
So.
Letztendlich
haben wir den Hackermodus gestartet.
Jetzt ist alles gut.
Jetzt kann nix mehr schief gehen.
Ah, yes.
Gut, okay, weiter.
Jetzt kann ich
die Qt4M wieder ausmachen.
Und die ordentliche vor allem einschalten.
Hacker haben überall Dark Mode.
Das stimmt wahrscheinlich zum größten Teil wirklich.
Kein Coding-Stream.
Doch. Da.
Hier, guck.
Big Braintime. Aber ich muss
mich gerade ein bisschen ausruhen.
Ich kann nicht mal richtig nachdenken heute.
Moment. Deine Qt4M.
Ach.
Sieht ja aus wie 1995.
Ja, einfach
danach, wenn man das gesucht hat,
also wenn man das gesucht hat,
ja, das beste ist,
wenn man dann einfach die drei Zeilen von
StackOverflow direkt als Root ins Terminal
pastet.
So muss das eigentlich machen.
Nee, äh, nicht StackOverflow,
äh, StackExchange.
Und auch ganz wichtig,
auch ganz wichtig, zum Sachen
installieren, immer, immer schön
das Github-Installer-Skript curl nach bash
schreiben, als Root, versteht sich.
Oh, ich muss demnächst Hetzner sehr laut machen,
fällt mir ein. Das muss ich mir da abgucken.
So macht man's, so macht man's.
Ja.
Wo sieht's aus?
Ähm.
Achso, ich dachte Root-Login.
Ja.
Ich muss
ehrlich sagen,
das ist
ja,
ja.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen,
das mach ich auch, aber
aus 2 Gründen.
Mal gucken, was er da dazu sagt.
ProClinX, Dankeschön für den PrimeSub.
Aus 2 Gründen.
Es ist einfach viel angenehmer, mit Keys,
weil du kein Passwort mehr eingeben musst.
Und wenn du dein Key verteilt hast,
dann brauchst du das Passwort auch nicht mehr und kannst ausschalten.
Das finde ich ist eine sinnvolle Geschichte.
comment in the actual ssh config here even states disable clear text passwords so is that true
let's have a look into the ssh protocol architecture to learn about how oh yes it's
big brain yes yes and here's a message password authentication where it clearly states the
weakness if the server has been compromised at which point you can already stop because there
we talk about already the case where the server is already hacked but still there are some caveats
so are ssh keys the better option well they come with their own issues the use of public key
authentication assumes that the client host has not been compromised it also assumes that the
private key when i know when i know that key geklaut hat ist vorbei mit key authentifizierung
das stimmt schon da hat er ich vermute mal was er sagen will ist wenn dein client
wenn er an dein zertifikat geklaut hat kann er sich einloggen dein passwort wenn du es nur in
deinem kopf hast kannst du nicht so einfach klauen ist schon was
ist dran post has not been compromised you see aber man kann übrigens beides in kombination
verwenden du kannst einfach eine ein key haben der ein passwort braucht dass du ihn verwenden kannst
not perfect but we are talking here very small nuances and this has nothing to do with a strong
protection from hackers coming for your server yeah da hat er recht still wonder about the
clear text password that sounds really scary well i kind of skipped over word and that is
tunnel before ssh sends this kind of information it will establish an encrypted channel with the
server and inside of that the clear text password is sent so it's not actually clear text that's why
the ss i could do nubble das ist jemand aus hessen am start server has its own private key and that's
why you need to verify the fingerprint that's why you connect to it deswegen deswegen schreibt man
ja auch seine standard ssh options uh uh
host key checking no das ist nicht immer nervt dass sie gleich dass sich der key geändert hat
new server your machine remembers the server's public key in a known hosts file and if for
example a network attacker man in the middle is you or you mistype your ip or host name
the ssh client will warn you that something is not right with the connection maybe this
is easier to think about https so tls or ssl ich muss ehrlich sagen da bin ich auch schuldig ja also
ich habe schon so oft einfach gesagt drauf key hat sich geändert wird nichts schlimmes sein
passt schon different protocol from ssh but the result is very similar when you log into youtube
live overflow from the future here i thought i make an example with youtube instagram turns
out they do weird stuff when authenticating so i will continue show some twitter login
you also send a clear text password in the http request but it's inside the encrypted tls tunnel
thanks to https so if you have a network attacker that man in the middle is your connection the
browser will warn you about it and refuse to send your path anzeige ist groß direkt purt and that
already tells you the ssh password authentication is not much different from using a password to log
into gmail or instagram and would you consider that to be dangerous too but yes it is still
passwords so typisch für das das das gleiche beispiel wäre hat er natürlich
Das gleiche Beispiel wäre, wenn der Webserver auf der anderen Seite gehackermant wurde und der alle Passwörter mitloggt oder alle Logins oder was auch immer.
Deswegen sagt man ja normalerweise, hey, du verschickst überhaupt kein Passwort, sondern du verschickst eigentlich nur den Passwort-Hash.
Genau das, genau meine Meinung.
Ich mache das auch mit Keys, hauptsächlich, weil es easy ist und du nicht laufend Passwörter eintippen musst.
It just means I don't have to use Password Manager to copy.
Genau der gleiche Grund wie bei mir.
Use SSH Keys is a useful recommendation, but not really for security.
It doesn't make your server magically more secure.
It's a convenient thing.
And yes, if convenience even decreases the likelihood of mistakes, it's probably the preferred method.
Another SSH-related server-hardening recommendation is to disable direct...
Ja, mache ich aber auch selten.
Muss ich ehrlich sagen.
...Root-Login and instead create an unprivileged user without root permissions.
Now generally, it always makes sense to use the least amount of privileges you need to do your job.
This is a very important security aspect for our software.
For example, the web server NGINX does not run as root, but instead creates a new, unprivileged user,
and when it started as root, it drops its own privileges.
If now an attacker exploits the website that was running on NGINX,
the attacker...
...would not have those root privileges.
The attacker would have those privileges and not be root.
So it seems like this is a reasonable recommendation to do the same for when you are working on the server.
But on second thought, it doesn't make much sense.
Two reasons.
Ja, du willst ja root werden.
First of all, the purpose of a server is different than your local workstation laptop.
On a laptop you do a lot of stuff that doesn't require root permissions.
Browsing the internet, writing text documents...
Genau, und wenn du auf dem Server bist...
Das erste, was du machst, ist eh sudo.
Immer.
Also ich könnte mir eigentlich sudo –i schon in irgendeinem Login-Skript hämmern,
weil das das erste ist, was ich mache.
Ich mache als mein normaler User auf dem Server so gut wie nie was.
99% der Zeit bin ich root und das erste, was ich mache, ist sudo –i.
Python-Applications, playing games, whatever.
It's unnecessary to run around as root.
And if you accidentally execute a malicious...
Also ich dachte immer, Moose, also...
Gerade SuperTuxCard, dachte ich, läuft besser, wenn man das als root ausführt.
...Programm, that you downloaded from a file-sharing site, then the malware doesn't run as root.
But a server you use very differently.
Für jemand, der keine Ahnung hat, was ist sudo?
Sudo ist ein Programm, wo du mit deinem normalen User-Admin-User wirst.
Also im Prinzip das Gleiche, wie wenn du unter Windows...
Das ist was ähnliches.
Wie wenn du unter Windows sagst, ausführen als Admin.
Nur, dass du das unter Linux auf der Konsole machst.
...use a server to set up a service, like a website, and then you let that run.
You don't really work on that server.
And to install those services and web servers, you need to be root.
So in the end, you mostly work as root on the server anyway.
And that leads us to the second reason.
A typical recommendation that goes hand in hand with the disabling of the root login
is to add the unprivileged user to the sudo.
Ja, wobei man da sagen muss, ich könnte mir vorstellen,
denn das bringt da gleich noch als Beispiel,
sudo hatte die letzten Jahre über...
Ich kann mich an eine riesen Sicherheitslücke vor nicht allzu langer Zeit erinnern.
Und ich bilde mir ein, es waren sogar zwei ziemlich große sudo-Sicherheitslücken in letzter Zeit.
Aber an eine kann ich mich noch erinnern, weil die war easy as fuck auszunutzen.
Du musstest, glaube ich, einfach nur...
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das noch richtig zusammenge...
Irgendwelche Parameter musstest du angeben dazu.
Ich glaube, du musstest einen Link machen.
Einen Link machen, oder?
Ja, und das irgendwie als Parameter anhängen und so.
Es war zumindest total easy, sudo auszutricksen.
Ja, das erste, was du machst, ist e-sudo-e.
They are the same.
By giving a user the sudo group, you essentially elevate that user,
to a root user.
Ähnliches übrigens auch, wenn du den User in die Docker-Gruppe steckst.
Also, da kannst du ihm auch gleich Root-Zugriff geben.
But security doesn't care about that it's indirect.
It's just one additional step that has almost no security implications.
Now, some of you may say, but sudo requires a password.
And if an attacker is the user, they don't know it, so can't become root.
But there are tons of ways around that.
The quickest and easiest I came up with is simply change the bash-Archive,
to add an entry for sudo, where you execute a malicious command
indicated by the program ID, every time the user wants to use sudo.
The next time the real user logs in and wants to do something with sudo,
they won't realize that they just executed a malicious command as root.
Again, here to just visualize the user-executed ID without them wanting to.
Now, sudo can still help with a bit of auditing,
what happens on the system through logging.
It's also easier to just give or remove the sudo group to users.
Especially in a team environment, it makes more sense than just to give everybody the root password.
But as you can see, those are mostly convenient.
Also wir machen es bei uns eh mit Zertifikat-basiertem Login.
Also sprich, ich muss weder Passwort eingeben, noch meine Keys verteilen.
Ich generiere mir einen SSH-Key, der wird gesigned, und dann kann ich mich einloggen.
...features again.
But it doesn't mean...
...magically protect your server against hackers.
The next tip I want to address is the changing of default ports.
Ja, da bin ich der Meinung, kann ich...
Mal gucken, was er dazu sagt.
Da bin ich der Meinung, das ist prinzipiell schon nicht unsinnig.
Also ich glaube, das bringt was, aber ich bin da oftmals zu faul für.
Zumal ich auch keinen Bock hab, dann immer dran zu denken, welcher Server, welcher Port und sonst was.
Und so ein Port-Scan dauert ja nicht lang.
This one is a typical...
Also...
...security by...
...obscurity...
...recommendation.
Ja, das stimmt.
It's one of the best snake oil examples.
Ja.
Snake oil meaning...
Da ist schon was dran.
...no real medical value sold as a remedy for all diseases.
The explanations for why we want to do that can range from anywhere like
everything can be hacked so we must hide SSH
to people will try to brute force if they know there is SSH on port 2020.
The term everything can be hacked deserves its own video to explore.
My TLDR is...
Sure, I guess, we can say that, but when people use it...
Also, warum ich denke, dass es was, dass es was bringen könnte, ist, dass du die ganzen
Standard, äh, wir scannen das halbe Internet durch, erst mal, naja, gut, wenn die kompletten
Ports gern machen, hast du eh gelitten, dass du die erst mal nicht direkt bei dir auf dem
Port drauf hast.
Especially in this context, most of the time it's used for fearmongering to insinuate an
urgency to this recommendation.
I'm telling you, an adversary who has the capabilities to just hack into SSH is so powerful
that we losers are not a target.
But most importantly a port change wouldn't stop that kind of attacker.
If such a crazy ODAY is made public or is used by some government agency, a port change
won't help you.
Das stimmt.
A port change might only have an effect against script kiddies and automated scanners that
look for SSH.
Genau.
Und das, was, und das, was im Chat gerade steht, du hast dann halt erst mal keine 5000
fehlgeschlagenen Logins aus Russland und China.
Weak passwords.
So try to think about this yourself.
If the attack is to try out weak passwords or brute force passwords, the actual security
fix is to have either a strong password, as mentioned before, or only use SSH keys.
That's the real defense against this.
Das stimmt.
The password is snake oil.
It doesn't address the root medical issue.
It just makes you believe you did something for security because somebody said so.
Unfortunately, the placebo effect was not yet proven for computers.
But if you are looking for a master's thesis topic in computer science, that might be a
tool for your own research.
Er hat schon, er hat ja schon recht.
Also, wenn, also, wenn, wenn du ein scheiß Passwort hast oder irgendwas anderes verkackt
hast, dann wird es dich nicht retten, dass du es auf einem anderen Port hast.
Another weird SSH setting that some of these guides recommend is to...
Okay, das kennt ihr schon?
Also, wenn, wenn, wenn, wenn du ein scheiß Passwort hast, ne, oder irgendwas anderes
Da hat er schon recht. Also wenn du ein scheiß Passwort hast oder irgendwas anderes verkackt hast, dann wird es dich nicht retten, dass du es auf einem anderen Port hast.
Okay, das kenne ich nicht. Das habe ich noch nie gehört. Das habe ich noch nie gehört.
Okay, das gibt wirklich keinen Sinn.
Gut, ich meine, natürlich, man könnte sagen, ey, wenn der Rechner generell nur Services IPv4 bereitstellt, kannst du Firewall-technisch auch einfach IPv6 komplett blocken.
Wenn du so nach der Taktik verfährst, bloß das aufmachen, was du auch brauchst, aber ein eingeschaltetes IPv6 in irgendeiner Art und Weise, äh, ein ausgeschaltetes IPv6 in irgendeiner Art und Weise,
das besser macht oder eben umgedreht, ein angeschaltetes, angreifbarer macht. Also da habe ich auch meine Zweifel.
Ja, das stimmt. Das stimmt.
Da hat er voll und ganz recht. Ich denke mir bei solchen Sachen aber immer, hey, an so weniger Sachen du denken musst, umso besser.
Also wenn du, wenn man sich angewöhnt, keine Ahnung, nach jeder Ubuntu-Installation machst du erstmal UFW an, dann ist das sicherlich nicht verkehrt.
Also wisst ihr, wie ich meine, wenn du einfach dafür sorgst, dass du an anderen Stellen dich auch mal vertun kannst und nicht gleich alles kaputt ist.
Weil sonst könntest du ja wieder sagen, okay, du kannst generell auf...
Du kannst ja alles verzichten, wenn dir eine Firewall richtig eingestellt ist.
Natürlich hat er recht. Das eigentliche Problem ist, dass deine Firewall davor kacke eingestellt ist.
Aber wie gesagt, wenn es danach geht, ähm, könntest du ja alles andere sparen.
Also nach dem Motto, wie, ich habe 500 offene Ports drauf, brauche ich ja nicht, weil, brauche ich ja nicht, äh, nix, nix zumachen, nix irgendwie gucken, was da alles...
Ich habe ja eine lokale, ich habe, ich habe ja eine Firewall davor stehen.
Also, ja, das stimmt schon.
Aber ich finde...
...Port zu beugen, dass man mal selbst Kacke baut, ist auch nicht so verkehrt.
Not the fact that you support IPv6.
Not to mention that server Firewall recommendations are weird.
Anyway, I get to that in a second.
IPv6 also has some concerns for actual bigger networks.
IPv4 NAT is basically the best Firewall we have at home.
Ja, ja, ja, das stimmt. Da hat er, da hat er recht.
Also ich meine, wenn, äh, also meine Firewall macht genau das gleiche, ja, wenn man die richtig eingestellt hat.
Das ist halt, dass defaultmäßig nichts durchkommt.
Du kannst bei NAT nichts falsch konfigurieren.
Das ist, ohne zusätzliche Einstellung ist es halt erst mal einfach dicht.
Das ist zwar keine, das stimmt, das ist keine Firewall, aber es hat im Prinzip den gleichen Effekt.
Wenn du IPv6 nimmst und, was sagst du hier, default deny and only allow das und das,
hat es den gleichen Effekt, wie wenn du NAT hast und einfach Portweiterleitung machst für die zwei Dienste, die du brauchst.
Also standardmäßig zu.
Und du musst die Sachen erlauben, die du weiterleiten willst.
Ja, es ist was komplett anderes und es ist auch nie als Firewall gedacht gewesen.
Aber der Effekt von außen ist der gleiche.
Das stimmt. Im Internet ist es eh egal.
Wenn du für dieses Video suchst, bist du wahrscheinlich nicht bereit, dein eigenes professionelles Netzwerk zu bauen.
Ansonsten, als ich diese IPv6-Recommendation gesehen habe, habe ich es als Lüge auf Twitter gepostet und ich habe eine extrem lustige Antwort bekommen.
Für jetzt, macht SSH nur auf IPv6 zu hören, stoppt automatische Login-Einstellungen mehr effektiv als zu verhindern, dass man es nicht verhindert.
Das ist im Grunde die bessere, geänderten Default-Port-Recommendation.
Script-Kiddies versuchen nicht so viel IPv6 noch.
Also, wenn du SSH-Listung hast, dann ist es nicht so, dass du IPv6 nur auf IPv6 hörst.
Also, wenn du SSH-Listung hast, dann ist es nicht so, dass IPv6 nur auf IPv6 hörst.
Und du IPv4 verlängerst, dann wäre das noch effektiver als SSH-Listung auf einem anderen Port zu machen.
Ich glaube, das ist ein tolles Gegenteil.
Und Lüge aside, eine Text-Surface-Reduktion ist im Allgemeinen ein sehr guter Paradigmen.
Also, vielleicht verlängern wir IPv6 auf der ganzen Netzwerks-Interface, nicht nur die SSH-Setting.
Vielleicht können wir darüber diskutieren.
Aber die Artikel, die wir hier veröffentlichen, sind nicht so einfach.
Die Artikel, die wir hier veröffentlichen, sind nicht so einfach.
results, miss mature effect for security
If anything. You might get a false sense of security
Now let's talk about firewalls.
ja, finde ….
finde ich auch nicht verkehrt, das standardmäßig einzuschalten.
You need a complicated firewall
you need a complicated firewall
block ports i think firewall is a really unfortunate term because it sounds really cool
and really powerful as if every hacker trying to walk through a firewall dies in burning agony
firewalls come in different complexities and features but the basic firewall settings these
resources recommend are just about blocking all ports and open the ones you need block everything
except ssh and the web server on port 4v3 das das das bin ich jetzt eigentlich schon sinnig
this is not different from simply just having ssh listening on port 2020 and have your web
server listening on das stimmt das stimmt nur das ist das also da muss ich sagen das sehe ich
ein bisschen anders kann man sich kann man sich aber sicherlich drüber streiten um das ist das
was ich vorhin gesagt habe manchmal ist es nicht verkehrt so was zu machen dass man sich selbst
halt nicht ins
bein schießt wenn du jetzt zum beispiel mal irgendwas anderes startest hast halt gelitten
oder weil du mal irgendwas nicht aufgepasst hat oder aufgepasst hast oder was auch immer
also das finde ich nicht nicht verkehrt das startmäßig einzuschalten on port 80 and 443
you can confirm that with ss or netstat to see what is listening publicly to visualize this
by listening on a port you allow the outside to interact with the service listening here is a piece of
paper with three listening ports send me an http request to this window and i will respond send
me brute forcing ssh attempt and i tell you if the password was wrong now let's add the firewall as
recommended here ändert sich nichts block ja aber was was man daran schon sieht ist gerade hier wenn
du die zwei sachen übereinander hält wenn du jetzt hier irgendwas startest oder keine ahnung ich muss
Ich muss jetzt aber irgendein blödes Beispiel bringen.
Was weiß ich.
Du installierst aus Versehen einen Squid, weil du es einfach mal machst.
Keine Ahnung.
Dann hast du das Ding instant im Internet erreichbar.
So, das willst du ja nicht.
Das heißt, du kannst dir das Leben einfacher machen, weil du selbst zu dumm bist,
ohne dir gleich ins Bein zu schießen, indem du UFW eingeschaltet hast vorher.
Natürlich sollte man keinen Squid auf einem öffentlichen Server im Internet installieren.
Aber ihr wisst, glaube ich, was ich meine.
Du beugst deiner eigenen Dummheit vor, wenn du UFW einschaltest.
Wenn man natürlich das System aufsetzt, reproduzierbar, aufbaubar hat
und dann irgendwelche Ansible-Automatisierungsgeschichten und so, dann brauchst du sie nicht.
Aber wenn das ein System ist, wo du dran rumbastelst und ein paar Sachen ausprobierst,
finde ich es nicht verkehrt, UFW einzuschalten.
Einfach, weil du dir selber Probleme, also eigene Dummheit vorbeugen kannst.
Now you can use a firewall on the database server.
Only allow connections from the frontend server IP.
As you can see in my list, there are more things we could talk about.
But the video is getting a bit long, so I thought to do one more.
Auto-Updates.
On a typical Ubuntu server, you can update packages or the operating system itself
with apt-get upgrade or even apt-get dist upgrade.
And some resources recommend you to enable unattended auto-updates.
Da muss ich sagen, da bin ich auch zu faul für, das zu machen.
Und ich hab immer ein bisschen Bedenken, dass der komische Dinger macht bei Updates.
Oder bei Updates irgendwelche Services durchstartet, wo ich jetzt nicht will, dass er die jetzt gerade durchstartet und sowas.
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich hab Auto-Updates eigentlich in der Regel aus.
Which is again a lot more complex than these resources suggest.
I think everybody agrees that generally Auto-Updates are extremely vital for general public security.
Forcing Auto-Updates on Windows, Android and iPhones is great.
It's a bit annoying, but keeping those systems up to date is very important.
But again, the problem is that an actively used workstation with tons of different softwares
and users that don't understand the tech at all is very, very different from the use case of a server where you can run a service.
If you want to seriously host something on a server, then enabling unattended updates is a great way to disrupt and break your server occasionally.
Yeah.
Not every update is security-reliant.
And that's the difficult job of a system administrator to think about what, how and when to patch systems.
And for a larger deployment, this can be a full-time position.
If you host something for customers, you don't want to accidentally kill your servers.
This sounds a bit like security is in conflict with business and we always say security must always win.
But really it's not that simple.
Let's be honest.
If you just run a...
Frag mal irgendwelche BWL-Stonks-Manager.
Die sagen dir auch was ganz was anderes.
Das ist halt nicht so einfach, wie der sagt.
The likelihood that a serious critical vulnerability is found in them is a bit low.
Especially one that works against the basic default installation.
I really wouldn't worry much.
But still you could say, well, at least I don't have to care about if it's auto-updating.
So it's still a win.
But two reasons you should keep in mind.
First, when news hits of a new serious vulnerability,
operatives,
and operating system packages that would be automatically updated might not have the patch yet.
So if it's really serious, you might need to go into your server and do whatever is recommended to mitigate the issue anyway.
Das mussten wir bei Hardbleed machen.
Das war grausam.
Ah, eigene HA-Proxy.
Äh, warte mal, war es HA-Proxy?
Nicht, dass ich jetzt Mist erzähle.
Ich glaube, es war HA-Proxy.
War das Hardbleed?
War das HA-Proxy?
Ja.
Ich bin mir jetzt gar nicht mehr sicher.
Doch, ich glaube, bei Hardbleed mussten wir eigenen HA-Proxy kompilieren.
Das war lustig, ja.
This is a manual job, and it's a balancing act.
In a business where customer data could be affected,
you must have a responsible sysadmin who can deal with the situation.
While on a private small server...
Nee, nee, nee, administrator ist ausgelagert nach Indien.
Den gibt's nicht mehr.
...and say whatever.
There's nothing important on it.
Das macht jetzt der Big Brain, äh, äh, dev, devops,
engineer, cloud, solution, chief, architect, officer mit.
...can just turn it off for a few days.
So, if a vulnerability in NGINX or SSH is not the big threat, then what is?
And that's the second thought.
Whatever web app you are running on your server is much more attackable.
Maybe it's your own code you wrote that has vulnerabilities.
Nein, das kann nicht sein.
Meint ihr ernsthaft, dass sowas, dass sowas hier irgendwie...
äh, Probleme haben könnte?
Kann eigentlich, das kann nicht sein.
Also ich find, das sieht, das sieht schon, das ist ja quasi eine Ausgeburt von best, best practices hier.
Guckt euch mal die Variablen-Namen an und guckt euch hier mal diese schöne Casting an und sowas.
Also, kann eigentlich keine Probleme haben.
Das halte ich jetzt für ein Gerücht.
...you installed from GitHub.
These softwares are not covered by your auto-updates and most likely need to be updated by hand too.
Shit, ha!
To be fair, there are...
...webapps like WordPress that are so widespread and have such a huge struggle with vulnerabilities and many inexperienced people running it, that they have implemented their own auto-updating features, which does in general improve security.
But in my opinion, the benefits of unattended system auto-updates, given that it's not a silver bullet that solves all your update headaches, it's so little compared to the accidental disruption of your servers and manual work you have to do by running a server anyway.
And that leads me to the conclusion.
Yes, any of these opinions I shared are debatable.
You might not agree and you have better reasonings for doing what you do.
And that is fine and even awesome.
Because that means you have actually thought about these things.
The whole point of this video is to showcase and critically question best practices many people just throw around without any...
Da gebe ich dem Vordergrund ganz recht.
Unhinterfragte oder einfach nur sinnlos nachgemachtes...
...nur weil jemand...
...mal gesagt hat, es ist best practice, ist bescheuert.
Und die größten Ausgeburten dieser Sache ist ja aktuell alle, die der Meinung sind, sie wissen, wie man agil arbeitet, wie man Scrum macht, wie man hier Qualität macht und sonst was.
Und alle labern so irgendwelche best practices und Bücher nach, die irgendjemand für ein komplett anderes Unternehmen geschrieben hat, was überhaupt nicht passt zu dem, was man vor Ort macht.
Wo ich mir dann auch immer denke, ja gut, man muss halt gucken, dass das alles zueinander passt.
Und nicht, weil irgendwie irgendein Big-Brain-BWL-Stonks-Mann aus den USA vor 30 Jahren gesagt hat, so muss man es machen, dass es dann für uns auch sinnvoll ist.
...Limitations and caveats.
IT-Security is complicated and not as simple as some people believe it is.
And I think what you see here in this small example is exactly what also happens in the larger IT-Security-Industry with vendors selling you security appliances that supposedly protect you from those evil hackers.
Don't get blinded. Don't let fear-mongering get to you. And always try to dig deeper.
If you then have a good reasoning for why you follow one of these recommendations, that's totally fine.
And one last comment. The best advice I can give as an IT-Security-Professional on running your own server?
Gehirn einschalten.
Just don't.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich die beste Variante. Das ist wohl wahr. Und die zweite ist Gehirn einschalten.
Of course.
If you are still learning and you have never tried to run your own server, please do.
A thousand percent you should learn that and play around with it.
And quick reminder, you can use my Linode-Affiliate-Link in the description to get a $100 free credit to play around with running a server without any of the hassle.
And at the same time support these videos.
But if you seriously consider to run a service in production, maybe...
Das hat er mit denen bestimmt abgemacht. Das muss er am Anfang sagen, innerhalb der ersten Minute.
Und dann muss er am Ende nochmal sagen, 100 pro.
...hosted yourself.
That is a decision you have.
Being a system administrator is its own job.
And if that's not fun to you, don't put that responsibility on yourself.
That's what you pay other people for.
And that's why I run my blog on Ghost.
Or why, if I would program my web app, I would pay the higher prices for stuff like App Engine or Heroku.
Ja, das ist auch eine Option.
Alter, wupp wupp wupp.
Mal kurz, äh, chat.
Was ist mit einem Nass?
Äh.
Wie jetzt?
Äh, verstehe nicht.
Also was jetzt? Wie? Nass?
Ich verstehe gerade den Zusammenhang nicht.
Meine Firma sagt, dass ich Scrum als agile Entwicklungsmethode durchge...
Naja, so falsch ist das nicht.
Ich glaube, du willst wahrscheinlich darauf, dass Scrum an sich, ähm, nichts sagt über die so genaue Auslegung, wie man es jetzt in der jeweiligen Firma mit den jeweiligen Teams oder so macht.
Aber an sich ist diese Aussage doch so falsch, gar nicht.
Also.
Ne, also Nass würde ich auf gar keinen Fall irgendwie ins Internet packen, ne?
Wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Ja, die WD-Festplatten hatten auch letztens Probleme.
Aber ihr seid in der Regel immer gut dabei, wenn ihr Sachen nicht ins Internet stellt, die nicht im Internet zu suchen haben.
Die Zeit ist vorbei.
Das wird heute alles nach Indien oder Polen outgesourced.
Unser, äh, Netzwerk.
Ne, das stimmt nicht.
Unser, unser, unser, unser, unser Hosting-Anbieter, oder ne, wie nennt man das?
Unser, unser Carrier.
Unser, und was auch immer, der unser Rechenzentrum anschließt, der hat jetzt nur noch ne Hotline in Polen.
Und das ist immer geil, wenn man da anruft.
Die können nur Polnisch oder Englisch.
Und wir haben zum Glück nen, nen englischen Native, Native Speaker bei uns.
Also den, den schickt man auch immer vor, so nach dem Motto, kannst du mal anrufen für uns?
Sagt er, ja, alles kein Problem.
Und wenn der mit denen redet, Alter, ist der Wahnsinn.
Die verstehen ihn nicht.
Die, die verstehen, der, der muss alles fünfmal buchstabieren.
Da sitzt irgendjemand im First Level, der absolut nutzt.
Der hat null Ahnung, das ist so ne, das ist ne Hotline für mehrere, das ist quasi ne Hotline, die für mehrere Unternehmen Hotline macht.
Und es dann einfach nur noch weiterleitet, zu eigentlich, und das ist ganz, ganz grausam, Leute, sag ich euch.
Wahnsinn.
Du kannst vergessen, wenn dort irgendwie was ausgefallen ist, wenn da irgendwas ist, du kannst vergessen, dort anzurufen.
Das ist schlecht.
Ne, also, das sind, das sind, das sind, genau, das sind unterschied, unterschiedliche Sachen.
Nutt ist dafür gedacht.
Also,
Also, man muss sagen, ne Firewall ist prinzipiell dafür gedacht, um Traffic zu erlauben und zu blockieren, oder zu verbieten und dann zu erlauben.
So rum ist eigentlich besser.
Also, ne Firewall ist wirklich dafür gedacht, um Sachen zu blockieren.
Bei Nutt ist das eigentlich nur ne Neben-, ein Abfallprodukt, dass das im Heimbereich so gut funktioniert.
Nutt ist eigentlich dafür gedacht, also Nutt, das ist ja Network Address Translation.
Nutt ist eigentlich dafür gedacht, dass du mit einer externen IP-Adresse,
so wie man das halt nun mal bei IPv4 hat,
mit mehreren Rechnern bei dir lokal ins Internet kannst und die sich alle eine externe IPv4-Adresse teilen.
Dafür ist Nutt da.
Also, wenn du fünf Rechner bei dir daheim hast mit einer lokalen IP und eine externe IP, dann sorgt Nutt auf deinem Router dafür,
dass der sich merkt, welche Verbindungen kommen von welcher internen IP, dann schreibt er das um.
Also, dann schreibt die Absender-IP um von eurer lokalen IP auf die externe IP,
geht's zum, schickt's zum Server.
Vom Server kommt's zurück und dann übersetzt er das wieder um und schreibt die Zieladresse um,
nämlich von der externen IP auf eure lokale IP.
Also, das macht Nutt.
Nutt sorgt dafür, dass du mit mehreren internen Rechnern quasi ins Internet kannst mit einer externen IP.
Das ist nämlich alles, was du damit machen kannst.
Du kannst eins zu eins mappen und sonst wie, aber das ist das, was in der Regel Nutt beim Heimanwender macht, so.
Dass dadurch von außen keine Verbindungen mehr nach innen möglich sind,
ist eigentlich nur ein Abfallprodukt, aber eins, was für den Heimbereich äußerst praktisch ist,
weil man gar nicht möchte, dass jemand einfach von außen nach innen zugreifen kann.
Warum kann man bei Nutt von außen nach innen nicht mehr zugreifen?
Naja, ist ja eigentlich ganz logisch.
Die Anfrage kommt bei eurer externen IP auf dem Router an und der Router hat keine Ahnung, worauf er sich weiterleiten soll.
Woher soll er es wissen?
Also, stellt euch mal vor, es kommt irgendwie eine IP-Handshake, TCP-Handshake,
kommt an bei euch auf der externen IP.
Welcher Rechner soll darauf antworten von euren 20?
Das weiß der Router schlicht und ergreifend nicht.
Der kriegt was, okay.
Er weiß nicht, wohin er es weiterleiten soll und er kann nix machen damit.
Deswegen klappt das, dass Nutt standescheinlich nichts durchgeht.
Und was so eine Pornwiederleitung macht, ist nix anderes wie zu sagen, hey Huteur, alles, was auf der externen IP, sagt hey Router,
ankommt auf diesem port leite auf diese interne ip weiter ja also das sind zwei komplett unterschiedliche
paar schuhe der effekt ist aber der gleiche du kannst von außen nicht nach innen zugreifen aber
von innen nach außen nur dass nut keine ports blockt im eigentlichen sinn sondern dass es
einfach nicht weiß wohin es die sachen weiterleiten soll also nut blockt nix nut hat keine ahnung was
das machen soll bei der anfrage bei der verbindungs anfrage von außen und du musst
ihm explizit sagen hey diese anfrage dorthin dieser also dieser ziel port dorthin so und
ufw ist schon was ganz was anderes ufw ist eine lokale ip tables firewall auf linux system hat
mit dem was auf seinem router passiert gar nichts zu tun so sieht's aus so was habe ich jetzt hier
vergessen erst einmal ins internet dann ist dann da ist wirklich da ist dann echt nicht mehr zu
helfen ja hotline ist ja auch paints champ ich würde auch nicht bei hotline arbeiten wollen ja
nur mit dem unterschied dass das was playstation und xbox da schreiben von wegen nut typ vollkommen
an den haaren herbeigezogene bezeichnungen sind es gibt keinen nut typ das ist irgendwas irgendeine
bezeichnung die sich microsoft und sony ausgedacht haben um irgendwas zu beschreiben was technisch
sinn ergibt also es gibt es gibt keinen nut typ ihr werdet nirgends wo eine definition also ihr
werdet in keiner fachliteratur sonstwo irgendwo was zu einem nut typ finden das ist einfach nur
ein wort was sich microsoft und sony ausgedacht haben für dinge die sie wahrscheinlich selbst
nicht genau wissen was sie damit jetzt eigentlich sagen wollen das beschreibt in irgendeiner art und
weise ob du ports weitergeleitet hast von außen nach innen an einer playstation ob
man quasi anfragen schicken kann neue sessions starten kann tcp sessions starten kann von außen
nach innen aber so genau weiß das microsoft und sony selbst noch nicht mal vermute ich außerdem
ist es ein vollkommenes unding dass es überhaupt relevant ist dass das ist eigentlich ein setting
da sollte man sich nicht drum kümmern müssen die brauchen einfach nur einen externen server dann
sollen sie halt sich selbst was aufmachen gibt ja genug möglichkeiten löcher ins nut zu
bohren wie macht man sonst p2p dann mit einem server dazwischen also muss ja nicht auf dem
server spielen aber du brauchst ein sessions vermittlung server kannst du kannst du noch
machen natürlich ist das nicht optimal am besten ist wenn das spiel im internet also am besten ist
wenn das spiel auf dem eigenen server läuft es ist ein unding das noch call of duty bis vor ein
paar jahre p2p gemacht hat aber ansonsten brauchst du einfach in den vermittlung server dafür man geht
was vlc jetzt bei saturn macht warum um alles in der welt soll sich das irgendwann kaufen
ok das ist was ist das was ist das eigentlich was ist das eigentlich für ein scam ist dass es hat
saturn jetzt ein marketplace oder was das wird ja nettes wird ja nicht saturn wirklich wirklich hier
braun handels gmbh ist das naja dies die sind die sind was die haben eine massive webseite
richtig mehr mehr
seite seit april 2014 super das ist ja mal eine wahnsinns seite wird richtig bleeding edge aus
und gerade dieses logo vielleicht liegt das aber auch am tag wieder okay sieht aber auch nicht viel
besser aus die seine worte findest du sinnvoll im inhouse first level anzufangen das kann ich
jetzt schlecht beantworten also für mich war fast level nichts da würde ich durchdrehen damit ich
kündigen nach einem tag es ist nicht sinnvoll du musst kein first level gemacht haben fast level
ist von arsch lass es sein ich würde das thema it weiterbildung interessieren was hältst du von
den iak weiterbildung du meinst ist das fach wird fach wird für informationen wie heißt der kram
ehrlich gesagt kann ich dir da schlecht was zu sagen ich kenne keinen der diese sache gemacht
hat und im zweifelsfall ist ein studium wird
die sicherlich mehr honoriert als irgendein komischer ihk fragt mich nicht gedöns ist meine
einschätzung ich kann es ja aber nicht genau sagen wie sicher ist eigentlich ein vpn im heimnetz um
zum beispiel auf den auf das nass zuzugreifen es kommt darauf an wie du es machst also wenn
du unbedingt von außen auf der nass zugreifen willst dann ist ein vpn die beste variante muss
ich halt nur fragen ob das wirklich notwendig
ist also in der regel da muss ich muss ich ihm recht geben wo wir gerade das video guckt am besten
ist der zugriff geht erst gar nicht da hast du keine probleme er nach typ aus dem nebengebäude
genau ja genau das ist das ist eine nicht näher definierte anzeige von von microsoft in dem fall
sogar dein eigenes spiel aus dem braucht keiner wie machst du das du machst bestimmt auch lokale
aber dann über irgendeinen Vermittlungsserver, oder?
Klar gibt es NAT-Typen, die beschreiben, wie das NAT implementiert ist,
weil es hier kein...
Ja, aber da kannst du von ausgehen,
dass das, was Microsoft und Sony auf der Xbox und der Playstation
als NAT-Typ meinen,
ist garantiert keine Anzeige für irgendwie eine Unterscheidung für
das ist Microsoft-Implementierung, das ist Cisco-Implementierung,
das ist sonst wie was.
Das ist damit nicht gemeint.
Das ist ja noch schlimmer.
Also, wenn ich dieses Wort schon lese in Zusammenhang damit,
dann ist es vorbei.
Eine DMZ ist was komplett, aber auch wirklich komplett anderes,
als das, was an dieser Stelle damit gemeint ist.
Das ist einfach...
Diese Beschreibung ist einfach kacke.
Und ich finde es genauso kacke,
dass überhaupt sich da ein Kunde im Jahr 2021
noch in irgendeiner Ansatzweise Gedanken drüber machen muss.
Wie gesagt, First Level würde ich ihm lieben.
Das würde ich ihm im Leben nicht machen.
No Nat November.
Das heißt, Windows XP direkt ins Internet oder was?
Es ist ja schön und gut, dass sie das so beschreiben.
Das ist keine technische Festlegung.
Wie gesagt, diesen Begriff gibt es ja an sich nicht.
Das ist eine willkürliche Festlegung von Microsoft,
was die jetzt darunter verstehen.
Das kann man machen.
Das braucht man nicht.
Das Problem ist aber dabei,
dass dann die Leute sagen,
hey, guck mal hier,
tun so, als wäre Nat-Typ
irgendwas Netzwerk-Technisches,
was es absolut nicht ist.
Die Erklärung dahinter kann vielleicht jemand,
der sich ein bisschen damit auskennt, was anfangen.
Wobei die Erklärung, was du ja oben gepostet hast von Microsoft,
auch komplett haaresträubend sind,
von wegen DMZ oder sowas.
Was ja auch mit einer DMZ absolut nichts zu tun hat.
Da gibt es ernsthaft eine Beschreibung zu.
Naja gut, Sony Playstation, genau.
Wie gesagt, das ist einfach eine willkürliche Festlegung von Microsoft.
Ja, Typ 1, guck mal, der eine nennt Typ 1, 2, 3,
der andere nennt es wieder Open, Moderate, Strict.
Das ist einfach für den Arsch.
Vor allem auch schon, allein schon,
dass auf irgendeiner Seite wirklich was von DMZ steht.
Na, DMZ ist was ganz was anderes, als das, was die hier meinen.
Was die hier meinen, ist diese Geschichte,
was manchmal in Consumer-Routern als DMZ drin steht,
nämlich, man leitet alle Ports weiter auf eine IP,
was aber mit einer DMZ überhaupt gar nichts zu tun hat.
Ja, aber das Wort eigentlich ist hier komplett, komplett verkehrt.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das hier großartig verteidigen kann.
Das ist einfach nur Anwendungsverwirrer.
Vor allem, dass man sich überhaupt 2021 damit noch auseinandersetzen muss,
ist der Witz.
Warum kopierst du manchmal?
Weil das keinen Sinn ergibt, weil ich das manchmal mache.
Ja.
Ja, dann hat der bei mir...
Dann hat der bei mir Pech gehabt.
Ich meine, Connected zum Internet direkt,
wie soll man sich das vorstellen,
hängt direkt hinterm DSL-Modem oder was?
Kann das die Xbox überhaupt?
Keine Ahnung.
Können die echt?
Wusste ich nicht.
Aber ja, warum nicht?
Warum nicht?
Nee, aber wie gesagt, dass man sich damit überhaupt Gedanken machen muss.
Ja, das ist übrigens das korrekte Wort dafür.
Das ist keine DMZ.
Das ist ein Exposed Host.
Ja.
Wobei ich ja persönlich ein paar Port-Weiterleitungen da bevorzugen würde.
Oder aber, ganz ehrlich, einfach drauf scheißen
und erwarten, dass die Hersteller das richtig machen.
Weil man kann, ehrlich, im Jahr 2021 würde ich nicht von Kunden mehr erwarten,
dass die irgendwelche komischen Port-Weiterleitungen machen,
was ja teilweise gar nicht geht.
Guckt euch mal Unity Media oder Vodafone mit Carrier Crate Nut und Geschiss an.
Da geht das noch nicht.
Weil du kannst noch nicht mal Ports weiterleiten.
Das ist technisch einfach nicht möglich in dem Fall.
Und das ist...
Die sollen das einfach ordentlich programmieren.
Da brauchst du den Scheiß nicht.
Äh, Leeko, hast du schon geschrieben, wie du das bei deinem Game machst?
Hast du schon geschrieben, wie du das bei deinem Game machst?
Team-Server.
Ach so, ja.
Auch gut.
Ja.
Ja, das ist...
Gerade bei Unity Media, Leute, haben da drüber zu leiten.
Zu leiden.
Genau, wenn du Dual-Stack-Light hast.
Wobei Dual-Stack-Light...
Das eigentliche Problem ist das Nut auf Anbieter-Seite.
Was dazu kommt.
Deswegen ist ja Dual-Stack-Light mit Carrier Crate Nut.
Also sprich, du tunnelst IPv4 über IPv6.
Das ist der DS-Light-Part.
Und bei Unity Media oder bei Vodafone teilst du dir dann noch eine öffentliche IPv4-Adresse mit mehreren anderen Kunden.
An einem heißt übrigens offiziell bei Vodafone Unity Media so, auf einem After-Gateway.
Ja, aber ohne E.
Ich glaube, es heißt einfach nur After.
Weil es ja cool ist, so Vokale wegzulassen.
Genau, das ist das eigentliche Problem.
Das kannst du nicht machen.
Nee.
Also, wenn du einen richtig vollständigen Dual-Stack hast.
Ich hab das mittlerweile.
Ich musste aber da echt ein bisschen...
Die rechnen mir beispielsweise, weiß es nicht, weil sie zu blöd waren, rechnen die mir jetzt doppelt Power-Upload ab.
Was total hängen geblieben ist, aber gut, Vodafone.
Wegen 4 Euro mache ich jetzt kein Akt.
Wenn du einen richtig echten Dual-Stack hast, das heißt, du hast eine externe IPv4-Adresse und eine externe...
Naja gut, was heißt eine externe?
Du bekommst eine gültige, im Internet gültige, global gültige IPv6- und IPv4-Adresse,
beziehungsweise IPv6-Range und eine gültige externe IPv4-Adresse.
Dann kannst du das machen, dann ist das gar kein Problem.
Dann kannst du IPv4-NAT-Portweiterleitung machen.
Was aber meistens der Fall ist bei Unity Media und Vodafone, dass es eben Dual-Stack-Light mit Carrier-Crate-NAT ist.
Und das heißt, du bekommst gar keine IPv4-Adresse mehr, sondern du leitest dein IPv4-Traffic getunelt.
Du leitest über IPv6 an Unity Media und Unity Media hat eine externe IPv4-Adresse, die du dir mit mehreren Kunden teilst.
Das merkst du unter anderem daran, dass wenn du Google aufmachst, öfters mal Captcha-Fragen beantworten musst.
Das liegt daran, dass Google festgestellt hat, oh guck mal, von dieser IP, die irgendwie gerade 100 Kunden gleichzeitig benutzen,
kommen halt ein bisschen zu viele Anfragen.
Ja, so sieht es aus.
Das ist halt für den Arsch, dieses System.
Das ist richtig krass für den Arsch.
Das kommt ja auch noch dabei, dass ich...
Gerade wenn man kleine, kleine Games betreibt, würde ich mal sagen, selbst wenn man einen Server selbst betreibt,
ich glaube, so teuer wird das erstmal gar nicht.
Ich habe jetzt keine Erfahrung mit, ich habe noch nie Multiplayer-Geschichten programmiert,
aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, du kannst dir ja schon für ein Appel und ein Ei irgendwie einen 8-Core-Server mieten
und das sollte doch schon ganz gut reichen für ein paar Spieler.
Hab hier noch keine Zeile...
Doch, guck, bam, jetzt hast du was gesehen.
Jetzt passt's.
Was ist denn ein R-Faktor-2-Server?
Was ist ein R-Faktor-2?
Ah, ja, das kann sein.
Also, wenn du lokal einen Server betreibst und möchtest, dass sich Leute von außen darauf connecten,
ohne dass sie irgendwie einen globalen Matchmaking-Server oder sowas haben,
dann liegt das ziemlich sicher daran, dass das nicht funktioniert, ja.
Einmal IPv6-Port-Forwarding sollte doch gehen.
Na, das Schöne ist, bei IPv6, da brauchst du kein Port-Forwarding mehr.
Du hast genug IPv6-Adressen, da kannst du diesen Scheiß mit Port-Forwarding nicht machen.
Schenken.
Aber wenn du Traffic hast, der halt nicht IPv6 ist...
Also, wie gesagt, ich hab noch...
...richtig echtes Dual-Stack.
Äh...
Das wird dir nicht allzu viel bringen.
Und IPv6 zu vier Proxien ist gar nicht so einfach.
Das ist ne Wissenschaft für sich auf jeden Fall.
Also, du kannst...
Also, in der Regel ist es so.
Du kannst das komplette Internet erst einmal...
...mit IPv6...
...IPv4 erreichen.
Und das meiste mittlerweile glücklicherweise auch mit IPv6, aber nicht alles.
Es mag sicherlich einige Services geben, die nur über IPv6 erreichbar sind, weil sie keine IPv4-Adresse haben, aber...
...die meisten davon sind wahrscheinlich keine Services, die man verwendet.
In der Regel.
Das geht.
Das ist ja das, was Unity Media macht.
Wie gesagt, genau das macht ja wohl davon Unity Media mit Dual-Stack-Lite.
Äh, wir haben nicht weitergemacht.
Das ist ja reines, äh, reines Stream-Projekt.
Ob da jetzt mal wirklich was richtig Cooles rauskommt, wage ich zu bezweifeln.
Es geht einfach darum, dass man ein bisschen was zu basteln kann im Stream.
Ja, es ist viel auf jeden Fall.
Wie?
Wir haben mal, wir haben mal im Stream zusammen, äh, programmiert.
Der Noel und...
...und YouTube...
...Bin Film meiner, äh, Max FPS.
Wo haben wir denn hier da?
Er.
Wir haben mal zusammen...
Genau, er hier.
Hey Leute.
Wir haben mal zusammen...
...den, äh, Stream gemacht, wo wir, wo wir so einen Speed-Test programmiert haben.
Zumindest, zumindest, äh, sehr rudimentär einen Speed-Test programmiert haben.
Und da machen wir irgendwann demnächst mal weiter, ja.
Jetzt wird's, jetzt wird's, jetzt wird's, jetzt wird's Big Brain Time hier.
Ja, Moment.
HTTP, da, das, da geht aber da nur HTTP drüber.
Das, das funktioniert.
Aber die meisten Verbindungen, die du für Spiele oder sonst was haben willst, sind ja kein HTTP.
Ja, genau.
Das ist zum Beispiel auch so ein Problem.
Äh, ich hatte, ich hatte ursprünglich das Problem, dass die Telekom nur IPv4 hatte in ihrem Mobilfunknetz.
Haben sie mittlerweile nicht, aber vor ein paar Jahren war das so.
Und ich bei VPN bei mir daheim zugreifen wollte.
Und das ging mit IPv6 only nicht.
Ich hab dann ganz abenteuerliche Geschichten gemacht.
Ich hab mir einen Server gemietet mit öffentlicher IPv4-Adresse.
Und hab's dann selbst getunnelt.
Zu mir.
Aber...
Das kannst du ja normalen Leuten nicht zumuten.
Musst du mal fragen.
Das kommt drauf an, wie gut die Leute drauf sind.
Ja, Leute.
Ich bin mal weg.
Nice, dass ihr dabei wart heute im Stream.
Wir haben leider nur die Hälfte des Streams gebrogert.
Für mehr hat meine Gehirnkapazität nicht, nicht ausgereicht.
Aber ihr wisst jetzt ist Boomer Bettzeit.
Oder bald.
Bald ist Boomer Bettge.
Angesagt.
Aber ich hab lang keine Mordgeschichte.
Ich hab lange keine Mordgeschichte.
Ich hab lange keine Mordgeschichte gesehen.
Sind Mods heute am starren?
Modcheck?
Ah, nice.
Oh, girls.
Ja, ich fühl mich immer nicht wohl, wenn gar keine Mods da sind.
Da muss ich zu sehr drauf achten, ob nicht wieder Leute im Chat irgendwelche komischen Dinger schreiben.
Aber man muss ja sagen, hey, mein Chat ist wirklich äußerst umgänglich im Vergleich zu vielem anderen, was hier auf Twitch so abgeht.
Da passiert ja kaum was.
Ist ja kaum was.
Richtig, ja genau.
Richtig.
Cute Chat.
Aber manchmal, aber manchmal haben wir da trotzdem ein paar Sprechen.
Da haben wir Spezialisten, wo ich mich immer frage, wo kommen die denn auf einmal her?
Und da muss man ja schon bannen.
Get schreckt.
Ich konnte das hier, ich konnte das jetzt durchschauen, weil ich hab ein Plugin auf meinem zweiten Rechner, was Url Weiterleitung erkennt.
Ich hab auch drauf geklickt.
Also ich hab gesehen, was dahinter steckt.
Der Link ist so sketchy, ja.
Das stimmt schon.
Vergess auch Windows Update, ja.
Also Leute, wir sehen uns.
Bis denn.
See you.